bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille patrick boos auteurs
vidéastes de la chaîne axolotl sont des
trucs que tu as fait qu'il puisse
corriger ça bonjour les merci pour ton
invitation fait très plaisir
je suis très content aussi de détails
voir là et sinon savoir un peu plus sur
toi ce que tu peux être que commencer
par te présenter particulier ton
parcours
oui alors je m'appelle donc patrick boos
je suis effectivement le créateur de la
chaîne axe haulotte est donc j'ai
commencé par la radio - en fait dans les
années 2000 dont j'ai fait pas mal
d'années de radio et c'est à la radio
que j'ai commencé à raconter des
histoires j'avais une émission notamment
qui s'appelait exocet dans laquelle je
racontais des histoires étonnantes et
les effets extraordinaires un peu dans
l'esprit dax au lot
et puis ensuite quand j'ai arrêté à la
radio j'ai ouvert un blog en 2009 qui
s'appelait avec ce lot parce qu'en fait
j'avais découvert l'animal peu de temps
après je m'étais dit si jamais je refais
quelque chose autour de la curiosité du
monde
je pense que j'utiliserai ce nom parce
que la mascotte est parfaitement
appropriée au sujet et le nom sonne bien
et plus en plus il y avait une une
filiation avec le nom exocet donc voilà
comment comment le blog a acquis ce nom
là et puis donc voilà sur le blog ce lot
j'écrivais de la même manière des des
histoires des histoires surprenantes qui
qui donc toucher à peu près tous les
tous les domaines quoi sciences histoire
lieux surprenants personnages
extraordinaires et en 2012 ce blog est
devenu un livre qui s'appelle l'homme
qui sauve le monde
et puis ensuite donc l'année d'après en
2013 j'ai ouvert la chaîne youtube en
juin 2013 d une déclinaison là aussi
du blog et au début c'était vraiment
pour pour m'essayer à la vidéo puisque
c'est un média que je n'avais jamais
essayé j'avais fait de la radio j'avais
écrit mais j'avais pas fait de vidéo et
donc samassa n'a beaucoup plus et puis
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
une demande dans ce type de contenu sur
youtube à l'époque c'est en 2013 est
même pas encore beaucoup de contenu de
vulgarisation de connaissances et puis
après ça donc il ya une série de bd qui
qui a commencé en 2014 donc adapter
l'ex-soldate donc c'est que les
histoires dont j'avais pu parler à
l'écrit ou en vidéo qui était adaptée
par lé collectif de dessinateurs
donc là il ya quatre volumes qui sont
sortis et je prépare un volume 5 pour
l'année prochaine ça c'est un petit
scoop en passant voilà et puis il ya eu
il ya eu d'autres livres aussi notamment
une série de beaux livres chez dunod
donc terres secrètes lieux secrets
nature secrète maintenant qu'ils parlent
des merveilles méconnu de la planète et
parallèlement à ça donc il ya aussi un
spectacle qui s'appelle la veillée que
je fais depuis 2015 avec damien maric et
le principe de la veillée s'est donc de
faire venir sur scène des gens qui ont
vécu des histoires étonnantes et qui
gagnent les raconter
eux-mêmes donc sur sur scène au théâtre
tristan bernard à paris et l'a donc
l'année prochaine en 2020 on fêtera le
5e anniversaire et ce sera au grand rex
mais donc pour résumer oui depuis une
dizaine d'années donc mon activité mais
activités gravitent principalement
autour d'eux des curiosités de la
planète et du caractère surprenant est
extraordinaire que peut prendre le réel
parfois hockey est ce que tu veux
conquérir encore un peu plus au début
quand est ce que tu en arriver à la
radio a alors c'est vrai que je parle
assez peu de mon parcours mon parcours
scolaire on va dire parce qu'il n'a
aucun rapport avec ce que je souffre en
fait moi j'ai fait des études
littéraires j'ai passé un bac l et comme
beaucoup de gens qui savent pas trop
quoi faire après avoir eu un bac
lg fait du droit et là j'ai très vite
compris que je serai pas avocat donc
j'ai arrêté le droit et puis j'ai fait
une année de médiation culturelle et
communication là aussi c'était vraiment
pour pour faire plaisir à mes parents et
pour faire quelque chose à l'université
donc ce que ce que ma ce que m'a apporté
l'université personnellement quand je
dis ça s'était longtemps c'était c'était
la préhistoire en a mais internet en
2000 2001 2001 dans ce que m'a apporté
la l'université déjà c'est vraiment la
découverte d'internet justement et c'est
c'est la radio donc j'avais été invité à
la radio par un ami donc qui était qui
était dans la même promotion que moi
donc qui m'avait qui m'a invité à
participer de ces émissions est là donc
j'ai tout de suite eu un coup de coeur
pour la radio dès que j'ai commencé à
parler dans le micro et j'y suis resté
plusieurs années
j'y suis resté sept ans environ donc
j'ai été animateur j'étais aussi
responsable des programmes se traduit
elle s'appelait rage et radieux du
aucune radio locale à avignon et puis
aujourd'hui
elle existe toujours cette radio et il
ya plusieurs antennes à une à paris
notamment maintenant voilà et donc c'est
vraiment la radio en fait qui m'a qui
m'a donné le goût de raconter des
histoires et de faire des recherches
puisque donc j'avais une émission chaque
semaine et il fallait la remplir
évidemment donc j'ai commencé à faire
des recherches donc de manière de
manière systématique et organisée g j'ai
développé une base de données assez
conséquent de l'histoire surprenante et
de faits insolites etc
et puis ensuite way le reste est la
radio aussi d'ailleurs un jeu les faits
en autodidacte quoi j'ai appris j'ai
appris sur le moment et c'était valable
aussi pour la vidéo d'ailleurs comme
beaucoup de gens qui font de la vidéo
sur internet
j'ai commencé j'ai commencé tout seul
et donc j'ai appris le montage tout seul
j'ai appris un peu tout ce qu'on doit
faire en guinée où tout seul était
ensuite j'ai rencontré des gens
aujourd'hui je travaille en équipe avec
et qui dut pandora création et donc je
peux me concentrer maintenant sur les
recherches juste deux mois sur
l'écriture et la présentation mais mais
voilà donc tous âges les fernando
didacte essai c'est pas lié à mon
parcours scolaire ou universitaire
vraiment salée indirectement puisque
c'est par le biais de l'université que
j'ai pu faire de la radio
mais sinon il n'y a pas de lien
thématique revient du coup à la radio si
je comprends bien c'était déjà des
histoires curieux de faim de curiosité
et if he is still à l'exo 7
si tu veux l'idée c'était de proposer
chaque semaine
une sorte de version radiophonique des
contes de la crypte d'une certaine
manière puisque donc ont raconté avec
mon co animateur dont qui s'appelle
thomas brille et donc il y avait michael
i can see qui était à la technique mais
qui qui intervenait régulièrement dans
l'émission donc on racontait des
histoires des histoires extraordinaires
mais qui pouvait relever non seulement
du réel comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour axolotl des histoires avéré
documenté mais ça pouvait aussi parfois
relever du du folklore des légendes des
légendes urbaines souvent mais voir des
histoires des histoires de fantômes et
c'est donc c'était pas c'était pas une
émission qui était basé sur le réel
comme peut l'être accepte aujourd'hui
est en fait c'est au fil des années
l'émission a duré trois ans et ce au fil
du temps que je me suis aperçu que les
histoires qui m'intéressait le plus les
histoires qui m'intéressait vraiment
c'était justement les histoires qui
était ancré dans la réalité en
l'occurrence des histoires pour lesquels
on avait des preuves et fait admirer
documenté puisqu'il me semble que on ne
peut s'étonner à bon escient que si
justement on parle de choses réelles qui
se sont passées pour deux pour de vrai
et finalement toutes les histoires qui
relevait du surnaturel entre guillemets
ne m'intéressait plus puisque avec le
temps donc je m'étais forger l'esprit
critique assez assez solide et j'avais
fini par perdre notre temps d'apercevoir
que dans 99% des cas on pouvait toujours
trouver une explication aux histoires
prétendument par normal donc et ses
explications pouvait relever soit de la
psychologie soit d'une mauvaise
interprétation des faits etc etc et donc
finalement je me suis dit mais en fait
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est ce
qui se passe pour de vrais c les choses
on a des preuves et on n'est pas obligé
d'aller chercher ailleurs que dans la
bonne et réalité pour s'émerveiller pour
s'étonner et c'est comme ça que
donc avec ce lot est né en fait autour
de cet axe là vraiment aller chercher
les choses les plus incroyables les plus
extraordinaires de notre monde mais des
choses donc encore une fois avéré
documenté pour lesquelles on a peint on
n'a pas de doute quoi pour lesquels on
sait qu'il s'agit pas de légende
c'est marrant c'est le parcours parce
que du coup tu es en train de dire que
tout ce qui est paranormal ça tu as fini
par rejeter ça parce que tu trouves ça
ennuyeux j'ai une certaine manière en
fait je tiens à préciser que à chaque
fois qu'on parlait d'histoire donc y
relever du paranormal histoire de
hantise de fantômes où il y avait aussi
des histoires autour de l'ufologie etc
c'était toujours avec avec beaucoup de
recul et à travers une approche
démystificatrice la plupart du temps moi
je rappelais que donc ces histoires là
pour moi avait un intérêt folklorique
légendaire de la même manière qu'on peut
raconter légende et l'appréciait sans
pour autant y croire mais c'était
toujours avec beaucoup de recul on à
blanc qu'il ne voyait pas de preuve que
ça s'était passé comme ça etc etc
donc ça va jamais été ça n'a jamais été
racontée avec avec le avec la conviction
que ces textes est réel quoi il est
toujours utile a toujours du recul mais
effectivement comme tu le dis ou d'un
moment j'ai fini par me lasser des
histoires qui était présenté comme réel
mais dont on savait bien qu'il y avait
très peu de chances qu'elles le soient
en fait je me disais bon c'est sympa
mais comme quand une fois comme peut
l'être une légende quoi ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment moi c'est les
choses dont on sait qu'elles se sont
passées
parce qu'elles témoignent de ce
caractère incroyable durel quoi qui va
souvent beaucoup plus loin que la
fiction et ses mots c'est mon credo
d'ailleurs je dis je dis souvent que y'a
que la réalité qui peut s'affranchir du
réalisme quand on écrit une histoire il
faut s'assurer que ce soit plausible et
on doit on doit obéir à certains cas
comment scénaristique alors que la
réalité elle donc ne s'embarrasse pas
justement de de trope ou de schémas
narratifs tout peut arriver quoi et
c'est vraiment ça qui m'intéresse mais
c'est amusant c'est sûr que c'est rare
point de convenait pas c'est en avant
surtout dans les comités sceptique c'est
qu'il ya vraiment un truc facile on dans
le réel que il ya dire quoi faire avec
le réal mais absolument aller souvent
souvent même beaucoup plus qu'avec
qu'avec la fiction comme moi tu vois
donc ça fait maintenant
ouais un peu plus de 2 10 12 ans que je
fais ça que une partie importante de mon
activité consiste à explorer justement
voilà tout les toutes les histoires tous
les faits extraordinaires club plus se
dérouler et je ne cesse de m'émerveiller
en fait je peux continuer permanence des
choses incroyables et c'est un bonheur
c'est un bonheur parce que c' est
intarissable de retrait et donc à une
énorme base de données tu disais tu qui
complique sa dépouille en fait plus de
dix ans jacqueline tcc non-stop en fait
c'est à dire que dès que en fait voilà
dès que je découvre unis une histoire
qui me kim et ohno qui m'émerveille que
ce soit une histoire que j'ai pu lire
dans un bouquin que j'ai pu voir dans un
documentaire ou sur internet
je la note je la mets de côté c'est
valable aussi pour des faits surprenants
des faits insolites
je les note je les mets de côté et
ensuite je vois comment je peux les
intégrer à mes différents projets que ce
soit que ce soit des livres des bandes
dessinées des vidéos etc etc
mais effectivement j'ai une base de
données ou et que je que j'alimente
continue au fil de mes de mes
découvertes et ça n'arrive pas à quoi
bâtir là par exemple
hier j'ai fait un petit peu ce facebook
là dessus par exemple j'ai découvert que
les états unis n'avaient pas de langues
officielles l'anglais n'est pas la
langue officielle des états unis j'ai
trouvé ça fout c'est quelque chose dont
on ne parle pas et
le fait d'en prendre conscience ça
permet aussi de prendre conscience
parfois du caractère absurde et
surprenant du réel qu'on peut s'imaginer
extrêmement structurée organisée mais
mais souvent pas plus que ce à quoi donc
donc voilà c'est le genre de choses que
je que je note vont avec ça m'étonne
d'aixam eux ça m'intrigue sa mort sam et
merveilles je mets de côté et eu
peut-être ta base des données les
strictes skillman cette académie les
pages pas combien de notes comme cette
année beaucoup de choses parce que je
suis pas je suis pas super organisé ne
suis pas très carré dans mes notes dont
josiane partout il y avait des google
docs
il y a un joli d'appui qui s'appelle
pocket donc une pocket c'est une appli
qui permet de sauvegarder des tas de
contenu des articles que ce soit sur ton
téléphone sur internet
j'ai aussi des tas de not ouverte
l'appareil sur mon téléphone sur mon
ordinateur j'en ai un peu de partout et
du cou et puis aussi d'ailleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
très souvent je partage les choses que
je découvre que ce soit sur sur twitter
sur facebook sur sur instagram est donc
tout ça constitue finalement cette base
de données et quand je me replonge
dedans
justement pour pour un projet de halle
en l'occurrence je suis en train de de
collecter tout ce que j'ai pu
emmagasiner comme ça depuis les deux
dernières années pour le volume 5 dax
haulotte je replonge dedans je
redécouvre des tas de choses c'est un
bonheur oubliez ça donc voilà c'est
comme ça que fonctionne car y qui a
retrouvé dans un terrain de deux pages
de notes d'un livre là comme ça à deux
pages ça je pourrais pas te dire par
contre de not ouverte de pense-bête de
ce style je dois bien avoir deux trois
quatre cinq six je dois en avoir une
petite dizaine disséminées un peu sur
différents supports
voilà mais le truc c'est que comme comme
beaucoup de
dejean bordélique je sais gérer mon
bordel je sais où sont les choses et
voilà donc je m'en sors bien
cet exploit ya des formats différents
est-ce qu'il y en a qui préfèrent alors
je trouve que tous leurs formes un bien
sûr on leur leurs avantages et leurs
intérêts propres
surtout dans dans les outils qu'il nous
donne pour raconter des histoires
forcément la vidéo donc apporte des des
outils que le seul format radio par
exemple ne peut pas ne pas apporter ne
serait ce que sur l'aspect illustratif
évidemment et puis il ya aussi une
possibilité de mise en scène qui apporte
la vidéo et que n'importe pas
nécessairement les autres médias m6 a
toujours manière de mettre en scène dans
un podcast on peut très bien mettre en
scène quelque chose mais la vidéo
apporte les faits les faits de montage
on peut créer des atmosphères d'une
manière différente la bande dessinée
aussi c'est encore autre chose que c'est
passionnant de travailler avec avec
l'état le dessinateur différent qui
s'empare d'une même histoire
sous un angle auxquelles on n'aurait pas
n'aurait pas pensé
le découpage on en bd c'est super
intéressant aussi que mettre en avant de
quelle manière le mettre en avant
donc voilà c'est à chaque fois ces deux
nouveaux moyens de mettre en avant une
même histoire est d'ailleurs ben voilà
dans la bdeac soit par exemple il ya des
histoires dont j'avais déjà parlé par
écrit à l'époque où c'était un blog puis
en vidéo et la bande dessinée permet
d'apporter encore un angle différent sur
sur une histoire
donc voila et puis il ya le de la scène
aussi qui est qui et qui est un terrain
de jeu passionnant quoi puisque là par
exemple pour la pour la veillée
on a des gens dont ce n'est pas le
métier qui viennent sur scène raconter
quelque chose et je pense que si c'était
seulement écrit ce serait très
intéressant bien sûr mais la scène
apporte une dimension émotionnelle à
tout ça qui est très particulière quoi
je sais pas si tu as déjà regardé des
vidéos de la veillée faut qu'elle fasse
encore parce que les vidéos c'est une
chose mais quand on est dans le théâtre
il se passe vraiment quelque chose qu'on
est vraiment déterminés fierté
particulière il ya une émotion qui est
très palpable
sacré quelque chose ça ajoute une
émotion à ce qui est en train de se
passer une empathie et donc voilà tous
les supports apporte alors à leur
manière un petit quelque chose en plus
et moi en fait ça me plaît beaucoup
d'explorer tout ça et puis ça ça ravive
aussi l'intérêt forcément c'est excitant
de s'attaquer à une nouvelle manière de
raconter des histoires une nouvelle
manière de partager des choses c'était
ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé
aussi avec les nanos fiction par exemple
donc la non fiction c'est à la base un
compte twitter que j'ai ouvert en 2017
et au départ ça
ça venait d'une envie que j'avais de
décrire de la fiction puisque donc
depuis des années je rapportais des
histoires vraies donc je les rapporter à
ma manière mais je ne les invente et pas
cette histoire est donc j'ai eu envie à
force d'être nourri justement par par
ces histoires incroyables
j'ai eu envie d'en raconter à mon tour
et donc fin 2017
twitter est passé de 140 caractères à
280 et je me suis dit mme à cette
occasion justement date opportunité de
m'essayer à une contrainte littéraire
puisque je pense que de la contrainte
souvent mais la créativité c'est parfois
d'avoir des barrières les contraintes
pour à pouvoir s'exprimer de kant est
trop de liberté parfois il ya un peu
l'angoissé de la page blanche real ça
permettait se focaliser quoi et donc
j'ai commencé à écrire de petites
histoires et je me suis régalé à le
faire et à l'époque donc il se trouve
que dont je vais faire un bouquin avec
flammarion et l'idée au départ c'était
de faire un livre qui était dans
l'esprit justement des axes haulotte
donc la raconter une fois de plus des
histoires extraordinaires mais vrai
et comme je l'avais déjà fait en bd et
en vidéo je disais que c'était
l'occasion la de raconter autre chose de
faire autre chose et donc plus le temps
passe et moi j'étais motivé par l'idée
de faire un bouquin dans l'esprit dax
lot et plus j'étais motivé par l'idée de
faire de la fiction
donc j'avais proposé à man à mon éditeur
qui qui qui est un bien superbe
christophe habsi chez flammarion de
jeter un oeil aux nanos fiction sur
twitter ça lui a plu et donc c'est
devenu un livre donc est sorti j'ai
flammarion en 2018 mais une version de
poche qui est sorti en octobre dernier
et
et voila quoi donc ça aussi c'était
c'était une expérience vachement
intéressante par rapport au format de
faire des mini nouvelle sur twitter
puisque on est obligé de on est obligé
des purées l'histoire jusqu'à son
principe essentiel quoi c'est super
intéressant et de décortiquer ce qui va
ce qui va provoquer l'impact centrale
d'inde a réussi et je pense que les
meilleures nouvelles
très souvent c'est celle qu'on peut
résumer en une phrase quoi ça qu'on peut
pitcher en une phrase avec un high
concept comme on dit neil les séries ou
les films et voilà c'était l'idée
derrière de nos fictions et c'était
aussi une manière de rhône drôme où
voulait un peu l'intérêt pour la pour la
chose écrite quoi donc
donc voila j'aimerais qu'un filet de
bouzid je trouve ça rigolo c'est bon
mais notre mission est aussi l'idée luz
2 parce que du coup pour moi c'est
partager des trucs de maths sur un tweet
que ça aura des filles connaissent et c
atteint ses intérêts sans voile et
pédagogiquement si je crois que c'est un
exercice intéressant pour des faits de
d'être clair et concis c'est ma facile
mais c'est clair et d'ailleurs pour
avoir parfois rarement parce que je n'ai
pas j'ai pas les compétences suffisantes
pour le faire et pour avoir quelquefois
partager des trucs de maths donc très
souvent c'est des choses qui peuvent se
comprendre en tweed causé des choses qui
- m'ont fasciné sur un tweet
donc c'est assez rare assez rarement des
démonstrations développer quoi si jamais
quelque chose de maths qui m'a frappé il
faut qu'ils médiatement je dise non
c'est pas possible
le tel chiffre c'est ça devient un
nombre premier si on fait si on fait ça
voilà mais c'est sûr que pour les maths
vu qu'il faut une démonstration pour
longer la plupart du temps c'est
difficile de tout de suite
agrippée comme ça l'intérêt des gens est
encore plus leur leur étonnement
je tiens à revenir un peu sur les bd
commence à le prononcer tu dessines ou
pas du tout alors moi alors voilà
comment se sont créés les bd donc au
départ il y avait un livre qui s'appelle
donc l'homme qui sauva le monde et autre
source d'étonnement et donc ce livre est
tombée entre les mains d'une éditrice de
chez delcourt qui s'appelle mario amir
gagnant qui était une amie proche
maintenant qui elle aussi est une
éditrice super et donc marion m'avait
proposé way en 2001 dès 2013 en fait
elle m'avait proposé d'en faire une bd
maladie est ce que est ce que ça te
plairait de d'en faire une bd donc moi
en fait j avais jamais pensé à ça une
seule seconde
et bien tout à coup cette opportunité
s'ouvrait et je m'étais dit si je le si
je fais ça vous surtout pas que ce soit
un produit dérivé
comme il peut y en avoir beaucoup que je
ne citerai pas mais je voulais vraiment
que ce soit un objet qui a une vie
propre compte et puisse tenir tout seul
indépendamment de blogs ou d'une chaîne
youtube fallait que ce soit un objet qui
sont son propre intérêt est donc très
vite l'idée du collectif s'est imposée
parce que il me semblait que fait ce
serait intéressant de créer une sorte de
cabinet de curiosités de papier puisque
c'est un peu un des geeks comme ça de la
chaîne et donc le propre du cabinet de
curiosité c'est que ça mélange
différentes esthétiques ça mélange
différents domaines avec comme seuls
neuf coco comme seul fil conducteur
entre les différents objets leur
caractère surprenant est extraordinaire
et là c'était la même chose quoi le fait
de me de réunir comme ça différents
styles de dessin qui n'étaient réunies
finalement que par l'aspect incroyable
des histoires ben ça ça permettait de
retrouver cet esprit cabinet de
curiosités comment passer d'un style
hyperréaliste un style hyper stylisés
comme ça en quelques pages mais le lit
la bd est conçu aussi comme une espèce
de magazines une certaine manière parce
qu'à plusieurs briques il ya parfois des
des histoires en une planche
il ya parfois des
des pages de textes dans lesquels on gg
écrivait justement des faits des
informations surprenantes
donc c'est comme si les différentes
rubriques à l'intérieur de la bd et ça
renforce aussi ce côté justement un peu
cabinet curiosité pendant qu'elles ont
bien piocher comme ça on sait jamais sur
quoi on va tomber sur la page d'après et
pour travailler avec les dessinateurs la
mode de fonctionnement c'était
simplement au départ j'ai jamais établi
une liste de toutes les histoires dont
j'avais pu parler qui me semble est
adaptable en bd qui me semblait
intéressante a scénarisé
une fois que j'ai fait ça on a soumis
avec l'éditrice les histoires aux
différents dessinateurs des
dessinatrices et ce qui est incroyable
c'est que quasiment personne en quatre
volumes n'a eu de conflit avec avec un
autre dessinateur sur une histoire quoi
chaque chacun a choisi son histoire
bizarrement c
c'était super d'un point de vue
organique organisationnel parce que ça
nous a épargné pas mal de soucis ça et
voilà chacun semblait trouver son
histoire et ensuite donc selon les selon
les et les dessinateurs le dessinatrice
ça s'est passé ça s'est passé
différemment parce que il y en avait qui
étaient déjà très aguerris comme poulet
ou marion montaigne
ou un ppt et loeb un jeu enfin il ya des
tas de gens voilà qui était déjà des
poids lourds de cette cette industrie
entre guillemets et puis avait des gens
qui étaient des petits nouveaux parfois
parmi les quatre volumes de dax au loft
il ya certes un certain illustrateurs
qui qui n'avait encore jamais publié de
livre
il ya des étudiants aussi dans ses
premiers ouvrages
donc voila c'était très variés du cou
pour les dessinateurs les dessinatrices
aguerris ça se passait assez vite donc
il s'emparait d'une histoire pour la
directive à chaque fois c'est qu'ils
étaient libre d'en faire ce qu'il
voulait puisque après chaque histoire
moi je rétablis les faits avec une note
donc j'explique ce qui s'est passé comme
après par exemple un biopic août a
toujours excellé note écrite à la fin en
disant intel est devenue sa télé devenue
sable moi je rappelle effet ce qui fait
que dessinateur était et des libres 2
d'extrapoler quoi à partir du matériau
de base grecque ils sont restés très
fidèles voulait par exemple quand il
raconte l'histoire du choc mécanique
il est très fidèle sur l'histoire et y
en a qui donc se sont affranchis
l'histoire de base pour en faire autre
chose donc dans le volume 1 par exemple
c'est le cas de erwann surcouf qui avait
pris l'histoire de l'épidémie de danse
de strasbourg au xvième siècle pour en
faire une espèce de l'histoire de
zombies danseurs à la voile à walking
dead sauf que sous petite danse voilà et
vu que moi ensuite je rétablis les fait
ensuite
bah c'est pas très grave que les
dessinateurs se lâche puisque bon bout
du compte les lecteurs connaître la
véritable histoire donc pour pour ceux
qui étaient un peu moins aguerris ou ce
qu elle un peu moins l'habitude de faire
de la bande dessinée qui était juste
illustrateurs et illustratrices par
exemple il ya eu pas mal d'allers
retours sur le sur le découpage par
exemple sur sur les dialogues sur les
sur les chutes mais voilà donc à force
de à force de discussions comme ça et
d'aller au tour avec les uns avec les
autres on arrive à composer cet objet
hybride
qui du point de vue de mon éditrice donc
éteint d'un cas d'école
c'est un objet qui est passé assez
bizarre et assez complexe par parmi le
paysage bande dessinée et comme voilà le
premier volume avait bien fonctionné on
a on a fait un second sur ce même modèle
avec une nouvelle équipe de dessinateurs
puis un troisième puis un quatrième est
là donc il ya eu une petite pause parce
que j'avais d'autres projets et puis
parce que j'avais plus assez d'histoires
surtout pour pour remplir voilà et l'a
donc maintenant j'en ai assez du coup le
volume 5 normalement devrait paraître
l'année prochaine ok super élections
est-ce qu'il va parler des
est ce que va être papa aussi des livres
qu'il a écrits avec du no way alors pour
le premier donc père secrète voilà
comment ça s'est passé je pense que
c'était en 2015 quelque chose comme ça
dès 2015 après la première prise de
contact avec donc mon éditrice chez
dunod
elle m'avait tout simplement c'est une
opportunité exceptionnelle qui m'a
vraiment été donnée par le succès de la
chaîne très clairement
donc elle était venue me demander
simplement si j'avais des idées de
livres si j'avais des envies des projets
de bouquins et moi il se trouve que
voilà à travers mes différentes notes là
comme je te le disais tout à l'heure je
j'aborde beaucoup beaucoup de ceux de
sujets très différents donc il peut
s'agir de personnages avec des destins
incroyables il peut s'agir de lieux
surprenants il peut s'agir de l'histoire
scientifique il peut s'agir de tout un
tas de choses et donc je vais catégories
comme ça et il ya une catégorie moi qui
me plaisait beaucoup que j'avais envie
de développer cette sndd lieu qui
semblait
exister sur une autre planète j'avais
fait un article là dessus avec quelques
lieux et au fil du temps j'en avais
magazine de quelques-uns comme ça et je
m'étais dit que ça pourrait être très
intéressant de faire un livre qui
seraient entièrement consacrés aux
merveilles méconnu de la nature aux
paysages méconnus et et en plus de ça
bon moi j'ai toujours adoré ce qu'on
appelle les beaux livres c'est pas un
adjectif qualitatif c'est le terme donc
de ce type de niveau là c'est le genre
de livre quand d'offres ado haine et
qu'on pose sur la table basse j'ai
toujours les toujours beaucoup aimé ce
livre là et à ma connaissance qui avait
beaucoup de livres sur les merveilles du
monde sur le grand canyon sur la
muraille de chine etc
mais il y en a pas ou peu en tout cas
sur justement les les merveilles méconnu
quoi jeu mériterait d'être aussi connu
que le grand canyon par exemple mais
mais qu'il n'était pas et là je m'étais
dit il ya quelque chose à faire il ya
une place à a exploré et c'est ce qui
s'est passé donc j'ai proposé de faire
ça à la laiterie julie voilà j'aimerais
bien faire un beau livre sur les maires
de l'est du monde mais les merveilles
dont on parle pas dans les autres livres
sur les merveilles et donc saluer l'idée
lui a plu et comme chez dunod
donc il ya beaucoup de livres de
vulgarisation scientifique qui sont
écrits par des par des scientifiques
justement elle avait proposé de
collaborer avec un avec un géologue pour
apporter la caution scientifique au
livre puisque moi donc encore une fois
je le rappelle je suis d'abord curieux
professionnel qui essaie de partager les
choses qui est qu'il étonne avec et que
les gens du du mieux qu'il peut mais je
ne suis pas un scientifique et donc à ce
titre là j'ai pas j'ai pas la légitimité
de sortir un bouquin de géologie puisque
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse mais
je suis pas géologue quoi donc mais
proposé de rencontrer un géologue qui
s'appelle charles frankel et donc le
travail de charles dans ce bouquin là
c'était de décrire des encadrés sous les
articles
donc moi g
donc j'ai apporté tous les tous les
lieux et ensuite j'ai écrit pour chaque
lieu un article qui vulgarise et les
raisons pour lesquelles s'était désisté
des lieux incroyables quoi et donc en
racontant aussi parfois des légendes
autour des lieux etc etc
charles lui faisait les encadrer plus
technique plus scientifique où ils
s'attachaient par exemple a expliqué un
aspect du lieu en question comment de ce
lieu s'est formé comment les sédiments
se sont superposées pour créer telle
formation à l'étranger etc et et voilà
voilà comment ça s'est passé cette
collaboration l'un pour le pour le
volume 2 jusque donc le premier terres
secrètes a rencontré un joli succès donc
c'est très heureux de ça et du cours de
discuter d'une fuite et pour moi la
suite il fallait que ce soit le pendant
humain de ce premier livre là en
l'occurrence donc un livre qui serait
consacré aux merveilles de l'humanité
cette fois ci des temples des maisons
des des bâtiments hallucinant etc etc
et là pour le coup il n'y avait pas
vraiment de spécialistes en fait avec
qui collaborer pour écrire un tel livre
donc moi j'ai proposé à anne mon
éditrice donc de m'en occuper seul
puisqu'en fait il fallait surtout un
spécialiste on curiosité donc ça je peux
le faire et parce que c'est un livre
donc lieu secret qui réunit à la fois
donc de l'architecturé de l'est de l'art
de l'histoire la rampe et des tas de
domaines qui sont abordés dans ce dans
ce bouquin là et donc donc celui-là je
les portais les porter seul et pour le
troisième qui vient de sortir dans
nature secrète
au départ c'était celui qui devait
sortir en deuxième d'ailleurs nature
secrète mais il a été retardé parce que
je devais faire en collaboration avec 1
chercheurs du muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris et finalement ce
chercheur ne pouvais plus donc on a mis
ce projet en stand by et puis il ya un
an et demi de ça à peu près mon éditrice
m'a proposé donc de relancer le projet
avec avec pierre karner donc qui est qui
et qui est biologiste et et et qui est
alors je ce jeu je ne sais jamais
l'intitulé exact de ce qui fait mis les
professeurs en tout cas il par la
génétique fc sion c'est son truc
et puis là il a un blog aussi certaines
chaînes of fame kills où il parle
d'animaux bizarres comme ça depuis pas
mal d'années déjà et est donc je m'étais
dit que ça pourrait être une chouette
collaboration est donc en pierre et
entrez donc dans le projet
moi j'avais déjà donc justement un cumul
est une base de données assez conséquent
d'espèces surprenante
je vais bien avoir 90 ou quelque chose
comme ça sur 100 et donc avec pierre on
a écarté certains on a rajouté deux
nouvelles et pierre avait le même rôle
dans ce livre là que charles band
premier c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
donc moi je j'écris un article qui qui
aborde l'espèce d'une manière globale et
de façon vulgariser et accessible et
pierre lui à faire un zoom sur un aspect
très scientifique très technique de
l'espèce il est donc voilà c'est certes
un livre qui s'adresse donc aussi bien
très grand public qui a un public plus
exigeant mais déjà d'une part parce que
les espèces qui sont vraiment vraiment
surprenante est vraiment méconnu et en
plus donc
il ya c'est encadré scientifiques
permettent de rentrer un peu plus en
détail dans dans l'histoire des espèces
présentes et visuellement assez
incroyablement beau c'est merci merci
j'ai très très belle image très bien
prendre et c'est très joli et excuse moi
aussi d'écrire un peu plus ton
expérience quand les parties la veillée
et max ont repris par rapport à la ds et
comment est-ce que tu prépares les gens
passer sur scène ce que jean roux
l'habitude de passer sur scène ce n'est
peut-être pas si oui alors la génèse de
la veillée c'est que en 2015 ou un début
j'étais à londres pour tourner
d'ailleurs l'épisode d'étranges escale
de l'ombre et donc je fouine est dans
les bacs du librairie londonienne et je
suis tombé sur un bouquin qui s'appelait
the must the most m au th et qu'ils
étaient donc une compilation des
meilleures histoires qui avait été
racontée dans le cadre de cet événement
the boss dont qui existe depuis les
années 90 aux états unis et le principe
de cet événement je le découvre enlevé
dans ce bouquin d'un c'est de proposer à
des gens qui ont vécu des histoires hors
du commun devenir est racontée sur scène
donc avec une économie de moyens totale
quoi on est vraiment sur la transmission
orale tout ce qu'elle a de plus
traditionnel
quand on a des personnes sur une scène
avec un micro qui parle un public s'en
sort sans aucun artifice
il se trouve que il n'y a rien à dire un
plus fort en fait je sais c'est assez
marrant c'est quand je montre des
épisodes de la veillée tu sais parfois
tu montes des vidéos youtube à des gens
que tu as trouvé passionnante et
généralement tu t'aperçois bout de
quelques secondes que les gens
décrochent aussi passionnante que soit
la vidéo parfois c'est pas le cas un met
très souvent mais j'observe sa tête je
rentre intrus équipe est la personne la
regardent d'un oeil distrait
l e
et passe à autre chose eh ben j'ai
jamais observées çà avec la veillée
c'est à dire que le fait d'être face à
un être humain qui raconte une histoire
qu'il a vécu j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
rien de plus accrocheur et je pense que
il doit sans doute y avoir aussi des
raisons profondément atavique là dedans
qui remonte à l'époque on était autour
du feu dans la grotte et qu'on écoutait
les gens de la tribu en est en tout cas
voilà il ya quelque chose de très
magnétique comme ça très hypnotique dans
le fun de voir une personne raconter
quelque chose qu'elle avait pu tout
simplement et en rentrant en france
déjà le livre je les dévorer je pense en
deux jours et en rentrant en france
je me disais que c'était vraiment
dommage qui passe d' événement comme
celui-là en france en tout cas à ma
connaissance en france quand on monte
sur scène c'est pour chanter c'est pour
faire des blagues ou pour faire une
conférence mais c'est rarement
simplement pour raconter quelque chose
qu'on a vécu quoi mais du coup ma main
m'accompagnait m'avait dit ce serait
bien oui ce serait bien de de le faire
quoi ce serait bien de créer une version
comme ça française de ce concept là et
je m'étais dit oui il faut le faire ce
serait très peu est d'attendre que
quelqu'un d'autre le fasse en fait de me
dire tiens c'est dommage que personne ne
fasse
vivement que quelqu'un le fasse et donc
voilà dans l'avion de retour je me suis
dit ok je vais le faire mais ce truc là
et donc en rentrant en rentrant en
france j'ai contacté damien maric don
qui est qui et qui est d'abord un ami
proche et qui est qui est un producteur
de spectacles donc lui mais touche à
tout il fait pas que ça il fait du
spectacle mais il a il travaille aussi
dans l'édition et travailler dans
l'audiovisuel
il a beaucoup de projets c'est c'est un
vrai rêveur quand il a été un enfant de
2,5 en quoi c'est vraiment un gars qui
aime s'émerveiller qui aime rêver c'est
ça qui le sait qu'il tient il a lui-même
vécu des tas d'histoires
incroyable quoi et du coup pour moi
c'était la personne idéale et je dis
voilà j'ai une idée je pense à pour être
intéressés dont je lui explique cet
événement qui s'appelle the most aux
états unis des gens viennent raconter
leur histoire sur une scène et c'est
aussi simple que génial en fait il ya eu
tout de suite il m'a dit oui il faut il
faut qu'on fasse ça et donc lui cette
eau qui s'est occupé de tout aspect
logistique de la chose donc il a trouvé
un théâtre donc celles au théâtre
tristan bernard à paris qui nous est
gracieusement d'ailleurs prêté par le
directeur du théâtre qui qui a tout de
suite aimé le concept est ensuite donc
il a fallu que je cherche les gens ça ça
a été plus compliqué puisqu'il fallait
trouver des gens qui avaient de bonnes
histoires racontées ça se fait pas sous
les sabots d'un cheval comme on dit donc
là s'en est suivie une longue période de
recherche légèrement angoissé puisqu'on
avait fixé la date
la première veillée devait se dérouler
au moins de novembre de cette année-là
2015 et triste triste coïncidence donc
c'était la semaine même des attentats du
bataclan que les attentats ont eu lieu
le 13
si je ne m'abuse c'est bien le 13 je
crois hélas veiller à la première
veillée a eu lieu deux ou trois jours
avant
et donc voilà pendant plusieurs mois
j'ai cherché autour de moi des gens qui
avaient des histoires surprenantes et
est donc josh on est j'en ai découvert
beaucoup parce que quand on commence à
dire autour de soi justement qu'on
cherche des gens qui ont vécu des choses
eh ben ça finit par ça finit par
affleurer quoi là beaucoup de bouche en
bouche à oreille qui se met en place
ah tiens il paraît que intel cherche une
histoire machin et est donc voilà les
beaucoup de gens qui me disent ah bah
ouais moi mon père il a le vécu six mois
j'ai un cousin qui a fait 6 qui a fait
ça est donc finalement donc j'ai fini
par réunir un groupe de six personnes
pour cette première veillée est sur le
papier c'était très casse gueule puisque
dans le tas y avait des gens qui
n'avaient jamais raconter d'histoires
sur scène je pouvais absolument pas être
sûr que il serait capable de la
retranscrire correctement face à un
public et en fait quand le spectacle a
commencé toutes les craintes se sont
envolés il ya vraiment quelque chose de
vraiment quelque chose de magique qui se
passe et qui se passe à chaque fois
depuis non mélangés plus jamais peur
c'est que en fait les gens qui viennent
assister à la veillée savent très bien
ce qu'ils viennent boire ils savent que
ils viennent pas voir une pièce de
théâtre
ils savent qu'ils viennent pas voir une
conférence ils viennent pas voir pep
talk
ils savent qu'ils viennent voir des gens
qui vont partager avec eux de la manière
la plus spontanée qui soit une histoires
qu'ils ont vécues comme si on était
autour d'un feu et qu'on échangeait des
histoires de vie aussi simplement que ça
et c'est vraiment rester le la ligne
directive de l'événement depuis le début
c'est venez raconter ça comme si vous le
raconter à des amis n'écrivez pas ce que
vous avez raconté puisque toutes vos
hésitations toutes vos émotions tout ce
qui pourra se passer même si vous
oubliez ce que vous avez à dire ça fera
partie intégrante de votre de votre
intervention en fait et c'est ce que les
gens viennent me voir ils veulent voir
quelque chose d'authentiqué tous tout
simplement quoi et donc voilà ça ça a
marché tout de suite il s'est tout de
suite passé quelque chose et en plus
voilà
à chaque fois c'était c'était des
histoires qui au départ était
extraordinaire pour différentes raisons
soit parce que c'était des histoires
très inspirante soit parce que c'était
des histoires émouvantes ou drôles ou
juste surprenante et donc je savais
qu'il y avait déjà le matériau qui
étaient là et ensuite la présence des
personnes leur manière de raconter ne
faisait qu'ajouter de l'émotion et ce
caractère authentique à l'histoire donc
ça pouvait être que mieux quoi et donc
voilà donc on a fait l'une on a fait 2
on a fait 3 puis l'a donc l'année
prochaine ce sera la dixième
la dernière en date c'était le 19
novembre hélas pour l'instant donc il ya
un peu plus de quarante histoire sur la
chaîne youtube
donc il va y en avoir cinq de plus cela
dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent et c'est aussi un événement qui
m'a permis de rencontrer des gens
extraordinaires mamans qui ont vécu des
choses mais absolument incroyable comme
par exemple sur la dernière veillée
donc il ya donc un aventurier
tétraplégique s'appelle samuel marie
incroyable donc c'est don sainghin
garçon qui a eu un accident de travail
quand ils avaient une vingtaine d'années
donc il s'est retrouvé paralysé et très
vite il s'est dit non je veux pas je
veux pas être réduit à cette étiquette
du mec handicapés moi je j'ai envie de
partir à la découverte du monde en fait
et c'est ce qui a fait quoi il a
sillonné le monde aborde dans le camion
ont été spécialement aménagés et l'a
donc trois jours après la veillée il
partait pour un pot l'antarctique et
donc ça c'est incroyable quoi et j'ai
ridé et d'essayer des histoires comme
celles-là des personnages comme comme ça
c'est un bonheur de pouvoir les
rencontrer quoi de pouvoir s'en ressent
nourrir et et c'est un événement la
veillée que je qualifie souvent de
d'horizontal n'est pas le vertical dans
le sens où c'est pas comme s'il y avait
une personne sur scène qui dominait le
public du haut de ses connaissances par
exemple et qui venait lui lui à lui
apprendre une leçon là il ya vraiment un
côté on est tous au même niveau et il ya
quelqu'un qui partage quelque chose mais
si ça vous intéresse
prenez ce qu'il ya à prendre et pas de
leçons quoi et d'ailleurs y en a
beaucoup qui me demandent menace il faut
absolument qu'il ya un message ou quoi
et j nantes vraiment les gens prendront
ce qui a inscrit à apprendre quoi et il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
qui sont s'identifient à une histoire
une autre qui viennent après poser des
questions aux différents narrateurs et
voilà depuis le début le début c'est un
concept qui fonctionne de cette manière
là et qui pour moi est juste et juste
comme comme un diamant brut quoique
yahia il n'y a pas grand chose à ajouter
tu vois le décor c'est à une économie
totale il ya six chaises posées sur une
scène avec un rideau noir derrière mais
ça suffit quoi et puis et puis aussi
qu'est ce que je voulais dire par
rapport à la veillée oui il ya un livre
de la veillée qu'on est en train de
préparer donc il a compilé certaines des
histoires et qui sera donc vendu pour
pour pour
alors je crois que c'est le souk
populaire oui c'est le secours populaire
qu'on a fait ça donc à tous les bonheurs
tous les bénéfices seront reversés au
secours populaire puisque évidemment les
gens qui viennent réveiller pour
raconter leur histoire mais il ya le
faire gratuitement
donc on va prendre de droit sont des
histoires que les gens viennent raconter
gratuitement ce qui fait qu'elles seront
reversés voilà des abbés a des bonnes
oeuvres
et du coup ça me fait vraiment plaisir
parce que ça s'inscrit dans l'esprit de
cet événement qui depuis le début portes
de chouettes valeur quoi donc voilà
c'est vraiment quelque chose dont je
suis assez fier de faire très très
chouette quand comment est ce que tu
fais pour sélectionner les gens et qu'il
va faire une sélection tassé de
l'histoire alors c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui peut se passer de deux très
grand nombre de façons quoi parfois
c'est juste quelqu'un qui me raconte
quelque chose et qu'il détient j'ai vécu
six ou alors que tellement j'étais petit
mes tarifs ça que je dit attends tu
t'intéresses ré devenir leur apport est
sûr c'est que vous tapez apple dîner de
cons est inversée intéressant et donc du
coup il ya des gens qui regrette après
avoir inventé des histoires mais qui ne
le regrette pas une fois qu'ils sont
passés sur cette scène très souvent il
ya eu des génératrices qu'il est
terrifiée à l'idée de monter sur scène
parce que encore une fois encore une
fois c'est pas c'est pas l'habitude de
la plupart des gens qui viennent mais je
pense par exemple à la lola qui était
venu raconter une histoire géniale et
qu'ils étaient persuadés en plus que son
histoire était pas intéressante que cela
n'avait pas d'intérêt
pour d'autres personnes vous pour elle
même mais moi j'avais dit sisi prends
moi c'est bien et donc finalement ça
avait été un des passages les plus les
plus jolies qu'ont connus et aussi oui
je ce que je voulais dire c'est que
depuis le début les gens qui viennent
donc à la veillée sont constitués à la
fois
deux personnes une personne anonyme qui
sont vraiment issus de tout un tas de
domaines et de tête de têtes connues
mais on n'annonce jamais qui seront les
intervenantes donc c'est toujours une
surprise totale pour les gens qui
viennent le public ne sait jamais ce qui
va entendre qui va voir ce qui
d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui continuer
à nous sidéré parce que y'a pas
communication l'avion ne communique pas
on fait juste une annonce quand les les
places sont mises en vente en général
maintenant au bout de une semaine ou
deux
c'est complet alors qu'on ne communique
pas on n'annonce pas qui sera là et
danser c'est une surprise pour les gens
voilà et et surtout les les
personnalités plus connues dont qui
viennent sur scène
généralement ne vient pas pour raconter
des choses qu'on connaît d'eux est
justement des aspects un petit peu plus
méconnus et ils sont vraiment sur tous
logés à la même enseigne et que tous les
autres quoi il ya vraiment encore une
fois cette idée d'horizontalité c'est à
dire on est tous au même niveau
il ya des gens qu'il aime partager les
histoires et des gens qui viennent les
écouter et puis voilà quoi
donc ça aussi c'est très très cool parce
que ça crée une ambiance souvent
surprenantes quoi quand j en vois par
exemple débarquer antoine de maximy qui
fait l'émission j'irai dormir chez vous
qui vient raconter justement en qualité
sa vie avant j'irai dormir chez vous
quand il était reporter de guerre à
beyrouth qui avait des trucs incroyables
ben c'est totalement totalement
inattendu surtout dans un décor aussi
épuré quoi dire que quand jonathan cohen
aussi était venu raconter cette histoire
hallucinante quand il était quand il
était à new york
il ya une vingtaine d'années de ça
maintenant et est qui qui qui cherchait
du travail et de new york et il nous a
dit nous a fait un truc exceptionnel
d'ailleurs c'est le seul épisode de
l'aveca dépassé le million de vues parce
que il nous a fait un show c'était fou
s'est fait à la fois drôle à la fois
émouvant et donc à des moments de grâce
aussi parfois kiprop qui peuvent arriver
totalement inattendu puisque encore une
fois les gens ne répète pas sauf ceux
qui veulent qu'ils peuvent répéter avant
mais il y en a vraiment racontent leur
histoire une fois qu'ils sont sur place
et est donc voilà pour pour découvrir
des histoires comme je disais soit ça
peut être quelqu'un qui me raconte un
truc genre j'ai vécu ça soit ça peut
être du bouche à oreille genre à moi je
connais une personne qui peut être
pourrait intéresser à la fée ciel a fait
ça donc là je rentre en contact
je vois ça intéresse la personne et si
oui participent parfois ça peut être des
recherches plus active dans le sens où
par exemple je vais chercher des livres
qui ont été écrits par ben pas par des
gens qui ont vécu justement des des
choses des choses hors du commun ou des
livres de témoignages souvent et
j'essaie de voir si la personne est
intéressé pour venir la raconter sur
scène il m'est arrivé aussi de proposer
à des gens de venir raconter des
histoires que j'avais entendre des
podcasts c'est le cas d'une jeune fille
qui est qui était venu à la veillée
après que j'ai écouté son histoire dans
le podcast transfert qui est un super
podcast d'ailleurs et voilà donc ça peut
se faire de tout un tas de manières
différentes et et ça aussi c'est un vrai
bonheur d'ailleurs parce qu'il ne sait
jamais quand ni comment je vais
découvrir une nouvelle histoire
et comme il ya de plus en plus de gens
qui viennent m'en proposait comme ça que
je recherche
et c'est vraiment une chasse au trésor
est aussi bien sûr on peut nous en
soumettre
j'oubliais on peut nous en soumettre par
internet donc sur le site de la veillée
et sur mon site personnel aussi les gens
peuvent nous soumettre leur histoire
tout simplement spontanément dire bah
voila j'ai vécu ça est ce que ça vous
intéresse
donc on a eu beaucoup d'histoires très
intéressant de m
aussi et voilà en gros comment ça se
passe ok est ce que toi tu fais aussi de
la scène quand tu présentes les choses
alors alors en dehors de la de l'abeille
et il m'est arrivé de faire des des
conférences sur scène pour différentes
régions pour différentes occasions on
attendait dans des conventions dans des
festivals
ouais c'est quelque chose qui est arrivé
plusieurs fois et que et que j'aime de
plus en plus d'ailleurs parce qu'on est
forcément mathieu tu le sais aussi quand
on est face à un public
on peut donc utiliser des des effets
supplémentaires qu'on n'est pas
forcément quand on est seul face à une
page blanche ou cantons contre ont créé
une vidéo on peut jouer avec les gens
interagir avec les gens et puis en plus
c'est un feedback un feedback direct sur
sur nos effet tu vois si tu racontes
quand moi je sais que une de mes 2 mai
grande source de joie quand je suis
amené voilà à faire une conférence ou à
prendre la parole en public c'est les
réactions des gens quand je raconte
justement une histoire extraordinaire
qui moi m'a sidéré quand je les ai
entendu la première fois et qui me ravit
encore plus quand je tends les règles
sont des gens quoi pour les as et c'est
un bonheur total
c'est quelque chose que j'aimerais faire
de plus en plus d'ailleurs
je dois aussi à ces pays qui est âgé
plus qu'à la caméra web à seclin et aux
plus gourmands pour toutes les vidéos et
où est ce que tu as les endroits où tu
vas chercher l'information ce qui est
ici privilégié où comment se trouve
alors vois vraiment pas macho et si
typiquement mettons que je prenne que le
sens voilà d'une histoire qui va
m'intéresser en lisant un article sur
internet
en lisant un bouquin en regardant
documentaire jeu mais cette histoire de
côté et ensuite quand je décide d'en
faire quelque chose quand je décide d'en
parler on écrit ou en vidéo
là je vais réunir toutes les sources
possibles croise évidemment les sources
je vais essayer de synthétiser les
informations qui me semblent les plus
intéressantes en tout cas qui
m'intéresse moi personnellement par
exemple pour pour tous les livres de la
série des secrets donc à secrets de
secret nature secrète
à chaque fois ce que je fais c'est que
donc voilà je réunis le maximum
d'informations possible et ensuite donc
je vais faire un trip je vais je vais
garder ce qui moi me paraît le plus
intéressant le plus surprenant le bleu
plus le plus merveilleux dans tout ça et
je vais le synthétiser dans un article
quoi et moi mon but et c'est un sens ça
que je je rejette le titre de
vulgarisateur parce que parfois on met
dans la sphère des vulgarisateurs et
c'est un titre que que je n'assume pas
parce que pour pour moi quelqu'un qui
vulgarise c'est quelqu'un qui met à la
disposition du grand public qui met à la
disposition des néophytes une notion
trop complexe à appréhender si on n'a
pas la formation nécessaire quoi c'est
vraiment l'exercice de passage ces voix
là vous voyez cette notion qui est
totalement hermétique pour vous bon je
vais essayé de la traduire avec des mots
clairs et plus je joue la donne parce
que moi j'ai trouvé ça incroyable je
veux vous ressenti la même chose
donc voilà je je le fais moi je suis
déjà encore une fois je ne suis pas un
scientifique et je suis d'abord un
passeur d'histoires un passeur de
curiosité d'émerveillement quoi donc si
je vulgarise c'est toujours au service
encore une fois de d'une histoire et
c'est pas mon but premier est de
vulgariser ce n'est pas mon but premier
de simplifier les concepts de simplifier
des notions moi ce que je veux c'est
vraiment transmettre mon éveil mon
émerveillement mon étonnement ma
curiosité
et parfois il se trouve que ça passe par
la vulgarisation et quand je suis amené
à en faire comme je suis autodidacte et
que donc en bonne autodidacte j'ai j'ai
totalement le syndrome de l'imposteur je
me sens totalement illégitime
je fais tout ce que je peux pour
m'assurer que ce que je dis et est
confirmée et est valable et inattaquable
et ensuite
bon ben je jeu l'utilisent dans une
vidéo dans un bouquin mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose auquel je fais
très attention parce que je sais que je
suis attendu au tournant et malgré ça
parfois il peut arriver que même en
étant certain d'avoir pris toutes les
précautions pour que un propos soient
soient justes dans s'aperçoivent que
quand on sait qu'on sait qu'on s'y
tromper jeu il ya un exemple que je sors
souvent c'est quand j'avais fait la
vidéo pour le louvre
j'ai fait deux fillettes de vidéos pour
le louvre et donc pour préparer ces
vidéos j'avais rencontré à peu près tous
les conservateurs du louvre quale les
conservateurs de du tout les grands
section du lourd des arts primitifs des
arts islamiques des arts grecque etc
et à chaque fois je leur avais demandé
quels étaient selon eux les pièces les
plus les plus étonnantes du musée ou où
les pièces les plus injustement méconnu
parce que elle avait donc telle ou telle
propriété
extraordinaire et j'en passe devant sans
s'arrêter pour aller voir la joconde
donc voilà comment ça s'était passé dans
un premier temps moi j'avais ensuite
apporter toutes les découvertes que
j'avais pu faire de mon côté sur sur
différentes oeuvres et ensuite j'avais
faim jamais fait un tri de tout ça et
pour une des oeuvres donc qui est un
tableau qui représente un combat entre
david et goliath
donc je m'étais entretenu avec les
conservateurs de 7 2 7 5
elle l'a même des peintures italiennes
de la renaissance
en fait il ya ce grand coup ce grand
couloir qui est couvert le tableau sur
ses murs il ya un seul tableau qui au
milieu du couloir un seul et unique
parce que ce tableau il est pas sur ses
deux faces c'est tellement qu'ils
passent sur une ardoise
donc quand tu quand on arrive de face et
bars et c'est david et goliath
et quand tu fais le tour c'est david et
goliath mais de dos donc ça c'est une
curiosité au sein du louvre est donc le
conservateur avait expliqué que c'était
un cas unique dans la peinture dans la
peinture de renaissance et c est donc je
me dis bon jeu peut en toute bonne foi
rapporté cette information
voilà ce tableau donc cas unique au
louvre et cas unique dans la peinture de
la renaissance et en quelques minutes
je reçois un commentaires sous la vidéo
mais très courtois d'une jeune femme qui
me dit que elle est allée à florence et
dans un musée est tombé sur un tableau
qui n'était pas de recto verso quoi et
mais elle m'envoie david et
l'indifférence est effectivement c'était
vrai et donc voilà je je me dis que même
quand on prend toutes les précautions
n'est jamais totalement à l'abri et je
trouve ça très sain d'ailleurs parce que
finalement l'esprit l'esprit de ruches
d'internet vraiment le hive mind nous
permet de 2,2
de corriger même les choses les plus les
plus pointues quoi c'est pour ça que je
trouve que yahia un faux procès
insupportable à mon sens ce qui est fait
à wikipédia non parce que
personnellement wikipédia ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir d'en parler
d'ailleurs parce que je trouve que c'est
peut-être la plus belle invention de
l'histoire de l'humanité je trouve que
c'est une espèce de rêve de savoir
universel gratuit con con qu'on ne
mérite pas en tant qu'espèce parce que
c'est parce que wikipedia continue à
voir cette image de non fiabilité les
gens méprisent août ipdia régulièrement
quand quand wikipédia et est évoquée sur
les réseaux sociaux ou en commentaire de
jean quelqu'un pour dire ah
source wikipédia c'est pour hind ahmas
alors que de fait vu que c'est une
encyclopédie collaborative évolutive
il ya forcément moins de fautes et
d'erreurs que dans une encyclopédie figé
c'est une évidence
c'est une évidence s'il ya une faute
dans une encyclopédie figé dans le vent
siffle médias britanniques à autre mais
un brin on pourra pas les corriger alors
que dans wikipédia avec la puissance de
l'esprit de ruches emploi et je pense
que les gens qui disent que wikipedia
n'importe qui peut la modifier
c'est des gens qui n'ont jamais essayé
de le faire en fait et qui s'apercevra
très vite que se passe ça se passe pas
comme ça donc voilà je trouve que cet
esprit de ruches
c'est une chance et c'est une force pour
essayer d'aller vers plus de deux
vérités sur wikipédia oui je sais pas
trop comment j'ai pas trop ce genre de
commentaire parce qu'être défendre un
peu des domaines parce que en maths du
wikipédia c'est ultra minces aussi du
vermont et les samares et les devoirs
des erreurs sur wikipédia et
connaissances toutes les enquêtes toutes
les erreurs que j'ai vues ont été
corrigés depuis tu prends ce moment il
ya je connais pas d'erreur suréquipés
dire c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas nommé
ça se corrige ça saute haut qu il est
rapidement et c'est ça c'est ça si on à
elles resteront pas longtemps alors que
sur une ancienne
c'est tellement drôle tu vois c'est là
on a un phénomène psychologique et qui
est très amusant quoi parce que si par
exemple pour pour exprimer la fiabilité
d'un travail de recherche
tu expliques n'a plus été source dans
voilà l'encyclopedia britannica ou
autres encyclopédies de ce type de
référence tout le monde trouvera sa très
sérieux et très bien viendrait à l'idée
de personne de dire si populaire
britannique a alors que de fait encore
une fois voilà il ya forcément plus
d'erreurs dans une encyclopédie qui
n'évolue pas que dans une encyclopédie
qui évolue et qui en plus est alimenté
par l'esprit de ruches
c'est pour ça que je trouve que c'est
une espèce de d'utopie qui est devenu
réalité wikipedia quoi ces voix-là
l'humanité peut enfin donc alimentés au
sein d'un même média tout c'est toutes
ces connaissances et en plus les
corrigés au fur et à mesure donc voilà
rente est là dessus parce que je trouve
que c'est particulièrement insupportable
et injuste ce faux procès qui est fait
très souvent sur les réseaux sociaux ou
dans les commentaires à wikipedia va par
petites histoires dans le livre la
formule savoir - je cite un passage
wikipédia pour le critiquer et entre la
première version de mon livre est la
dernière version en fait la page
wikipédia avait dit a été modifié donc
bien là si jeune âge j'ai critiqué une
vieille version de wikipédia et c'est
exactement ce que tu veux de wikipédia
c'est que ce soit aujourd'hui en tout
cas mathématicien qui me dit quelque
chose et versus multimédia je fais
confiance à eux qui paient
mais en plus de ça en plus de ça c'est
ça aussi c'est un truc qui à mon avis
est méconnu de la part des gens qui
critiquent la fiabilité de wikipédia
c'est que ya pas de propos qui est qui
et qui avançait dans wikipedia ainsi
s'il ne signait pas étayé quoi et donc
quand on quand on les gens qui disent
ben source wikipedia c'est pas fiable
c'est pourri mais il n'y a pas de source
wikipédia il ya les sources de l'article
wikipédia lui-même quoi qui eux-mêmes
renvoi d'autres oeuvres donc c'est ça à
tout et tout est étayée par par départ
départ des preuves par des documents
quoi ouais voilà encore sur l'équipe et
que les plus près de soi c'est par une
source ça suffit pas une source est
fiable en elle même s'il bossait des
méta-analyses un détective qui en
comptent beaucoup de sources mais c'est
exactement ce que fait petit pays assure
ben si on veut soumettre un article
wikipédia il faut évidemment qu'ils
aient plusieurs sources qui se croisent
à plusieurs sources fiables qui se
croisent pour attester d'un même fait
quiconque veut essayer de créer page
wikipédia et il va mettre une seule
source issue de nos obscurités web sera
évidemment immédiatement rejeté quoi et
je pense que dans l'esprit de beaucoup
de gens qui ne se sont jamais penchée
d'ailleurs sur le fonctionnement de
wikipédia qui l'utilisent tous les jours
d'ailleurs penchée plus que ça sur la
manière dont ça marche
n'importe qui peut effectivement créé
une page raconter n'importe quoi et être
publié
c'est vraiment une idée qu'il faut
chasser de la tête des gens ne serait ce
que pour pour réhabiliter
de la qualité de cette encyclopédie quoi
et puis son trait fin quand quand la
page et à vraiment nouvelle et même si
elle est documenté mais il ya des trucs
un peu ébahis un bonheur oui écrit en
gros que c'est un tout à feu puis même
sur des sujets controversés
par exemple le paradoxe de la belle au
bois dormant
je vérifie que c'est le cas mais sur les
sujets controversés
c'était pas écrit je vais combler cet
été c'est dans ce pays que rambo il
n'est pas que c'était écrit en gros là
ils vont enlever mais parce que il ya
deux ans des deux réponses possibles à
ce controversé et et une époque où tout
cas il écrit en gros attention c'est un
sujet controversé alors que jean prof de
maths et c'est vraiment controversé oui
mais voilà quand les sujets sont
controversés que il ya désaccord entre
les experts bayer wikipedia extubée en
avant le fait qu'il y ait un désaccord
entre les experts des réponses qu'on
puisse mettre quoi c'est bien sûr
d'occuper d'assez c'est vraiment jean
revenir sur ce que tu devais sur
l'assuré vulgarisation ce que je pense
qu'à pas forcément une différence énorme
entre ce que tu fais et ce que expire à
faire on veut dire ce que mickaël fait
pas ce qu'il fait de mieux je pense
qu'il ya en effet une partie où on
essaie d'expliquer des concepts de maths
mais il ya aussi une partie un peu
comique elle fait beaucoup ça beaucoup
mieux pour eux et je pense qu'au final
c'est la partie la plus importante
surtout en watts
parce que j'ai un peu peur en maths et
du coup il y six mois ils ont qui sont
dans un état émotionnel qui est pas le
bon pour apprendre à faire des maths est
ce que fait michael très très bien c'est
qu'il va susciter de l'émerveillement
cliquer bras m'en tombent
c'est vrai que d'ailleurs j'en profite
pour pour placer une fois de plus son
dernier bouquin donc il devrait même du
parapluie que j'ai trouvé moi incroyable
il je le dis en tant que que qq
néophytes absolue en matière de
mathématiques a vraiment jeu très très
faibles connaissances dans ce domaine et
j'ai trouvé le livre extraordinaire
vraiment parce que c'est vrai comme tu
dis c'est un très bon vulgarisateur
il sait transmettre sa passion des maths
il sait dire avec des mots très simples
pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est fascinant
pourquoi c'est pourquoi cesser ces
incroyables souvent et j'ai j'ai eu
environ 1/3 mambo par chapitre et il
avait par exemple que la nature et
multiplicatif est pas a dit yves quelque
chose qui - donc vraiment ne m'étais
jamais venu à l'esprit je m'étais jamais
pensé jeu penchait sur ce sujet là ça va
paraître abstrait quand je dis comme ça
mais c'est vraiment pour encourager les
gens à acheter ce livre est que vous
découvrirez ce simple fait par exemple
et c'est un peu comme je crois que c'est
léo grâce à une as a man qui a posté un
même en story instagram
parce que pour ceux qui ne suivent pas
les eaux grasset sur instagram
c'est un formidable formidable
réceptacle de même de qualité et
récemment donc il y en a posté un qui
disaient oui et si donc les maths alors
un temps il y avait un truc avec le fait
que les maths et est le langage de la
réalité est que la wii voilà et que
peut-être du coup ça voulait dire que
les maths
c'était le code source de la simulation
dans lequel on vivait c'est vrai que
quand on n'apprend que la nature
privilégie les multiplications on s'y
met c'est fou quand même quand c'est
quoi ce truc aussi précis que ça qui dit
peu qui peut sembler totalement humain
qui peut sembler être une construction
de l'esprit humain peut dire que ça
existe ça nous précèdent dans la nature
mais qu'on a l'impression qu'à com
pas de code source donc elles ont donc l
on baigne
mais voilà c'est sur cette cité qui
cette idée que madore il ya un chapitre
de mon livre sur le point de savoir qui
est vraiment sur ça peut le fait que bon
c'est puisque la formule de base et
mediative mai mais sap l'indépendant
dans la nature et du coup on peut
fortement les équations de l'évolution
offensivement une cellule qui se
multiplient par deux chaque réplication
on sent la multiplication qui apparaît
et là ça va créer des phénomènes nos
typiquement multiplicatif c'est vraiment
des trucs que je pense la plupart des
mathématiciens qui s'intéressent à
l'évolution sans doute être très
sensibles à ça mais je pense que la
plupart des mathématiciens sont pas très
sensibles à ça et je pense que très peu
de scientifiques sont sensibles à cette
idée que l'univers beaucoup plus
multiplicatif qui active alors que j'en
profite j'en profite de participer à
cette émission pour te faire une
confidence j'ai encore beaucoup de mal
- justement à expliquer ce qu'est la
météo le paysagisme là est vraiment j'ai
découvert sa part toi tu en parles un
petit peu vous verrez jouets et jeux
voilà ce que ce que j'ai compris au
départ tu vois envoyant des vidéos en
voyant les gens répondent sur ce sujet
là c'est que c'était manifestement
quelque chose de très important c'est un
big deal quoi vous et bon d'accord et
donc c'est à cette occasion là
d'ailleurs que j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait un peu deux approches qui
s'opposait au sein de la science donc
l'approchent bélizienne east et puis
j'ai oublié le nom de l'autre mais qui
est la plus utilisée d'ailleurs en
matière de science comment est ce qu'on
peut appeler l'autre approche soit
appelée fréquentes east fréquentes east
voilà d'une certaine découverte pour moi
j'avais même pas qu'ils avaient deux
écoles de pensée qui s'opposent et par
rapport à tout ça donc je suis dit waouh
ça a l'air vachement important quoi et
donc essayer c'est comprendre
et aujourd'hui si je devais
le résumé comme ça si je devais le
simplifier pour expliquer à quelqu'un
qui ne connaît rien du tout à tout ça je
dirais que le bayer sionisme donc c'est
le fait de d'accorder une une certain
certain pourcentage on va dire de de
plausibilité julie de crédence souvent
c'est le terme
voilà moi alors je ça aussi c'est un mot
que j'ai appris au passage mais je pense
c'est plutôt un terme technique on est
d'accord c'est plutôt de jargon quand on
parle de crédence parce que dans le
langage courant une crédence c'est une
pièce de cuisine ouais donc bon si je
devais le vulgariser totalement du coup
je prendrais plutôt le terme
plausibilité donc voilà on a plusieurs
hypothèses et on va leur donner à tout
une certaine quantité de possibilités
en faisant ça je dirais que c'est
possible attendre pour cent s'attendent
pour cent s'attendent pour cent et et
voilà donc pour moi c'est une méthode de
l'appréhension des hypothèses pour
expliquer la réalité
en gros c'est ça je suis pas dans
l'erreur si je dis ça alors c'est pas
juste avant de dire tout commenté par
les conseils juste te remercier de faire
cet effort ce que c'est ça arrive
tellement souvent que les gens quand ils
comprennent pas un concept qui cherche
pas à l'expliquer que du coup il point
de ne pas chercher à expliquer c'est
qu'après on cherche point c'est
difficile d'apprendre si on cherche pas
à expliquer et du coup je suis ce que je
te remercie de faire cet effort et je
trouve à le faire c'est vraiment le bon
réflexe à avoir pour apprendre et will
go c'est ce que tu as dit quoi sert en
l'idée de m alors je parle peut-être
plus de crédibilité que de plausibilité
si je devais non mais quand positif très
bien et c'est vraiment ça l'idée c'est
que ça nous intéressait c'est pas de
savoir si telle chose est vraie cause ce
qui va nous intéresser c'est plutôt
essayer d'estimer à quel point des
crédible
oui quel point on peut s'appuyer dessus
et on lui faire confiance et à presles
toute la difficulté du bannissement
suite c'est comment est-ce qu'on calcule
à quel point quelque chose et crédible
mais est ce que ça veut dire que du coup
le free kantisme c'est une approche plus
binaire des choses vraies en pref si je
simplifie caricature oui ça m'embête un
peu de dire ça parce qu'il ya parce
qu'il ya pas mal de frais kantisme
différence c'est un peu une difficulté
s'ils fréquentent isme ccara fait c'est
plus une boîte à outils le fréquentent
isme et souvent les outils que l'on
utilise le plus consiste à essayer de
conclure par dre par oui ou non
donc évitons quand on présente la
méthode scientifique souvent on va dire
que on émet une hypothèse on le cherche
à la rejeter
et si les données permet de rejeter
l'hypothèse il peut être et réfuter
d'accord du coup là c'est très binaire
c'est ouais c'est vrai ou faux on prend
un peu plus pointilleux on dirait plus
et rejeté ou pas rejeter d'accord alors
que dans le cas du bayer à nice mme les
hypothèses sont pas rejetées elles ont
juste donc une note plus basse de
crédence en fait et ça c'est ça c'est
comme si elle avait une note entre 0 et
est 100 et si la l'hypothèse elle
explique bien les données bas sa note va
avoir tendance à augmenter
j'aurai ce rythme est-ce que du coup
dans balises à nice mme on peut rejeter
l'hypothèse où jamais on peut alors
peuvent jamais vraiment rejeté et a rien
dit peut-être qu'on peut rejeter mais
c'est ce sont des mauvaises hypothèse
parce que c'est l'hypothèse qui n'inclut
aucune incertitude mais par exemple
youtube arguant qu'en comme comme
l'existence de dieu par exemple alors
une existence à just est pas le meilleur
exemple
parce que dans tout cas je dis que qui
va plus aucune incertitude
parce qu'ici parce que si je te dis que
dieu existe
qui est telle qu'elle est la météo de
demain
le fait que dieu existe n'implique pas
quelque chose de certain pour la météo
de demain passe même pas car ce que ça
implique mais non papa donc si on peut
prendre des lois un peu plus attendant
que des lois de la physique souvent
qu'on considère des lois de la physique
souvent il ya toujours un peu une
incertitude qui est caché nous parents
si on prend les lois de newton des lois
de la mécanique des sourds une
incertitude qui en fait réside dans
l'état actuel de l'univers pour faire
une prédiction concentre sur le futur on
pourra faire la prédiction exacte si on
connaissait l'état exact de l'univers
sauf qu'en pratique une incertitude donc
si on inclue dans notre modèle de notre
façon de penser de l'incertitude sur les
lois sur l'état physique de l'univers
mais là on va t'amener à faire des
prédictions probabiliste sur le futur
exactement la météo la vidéo c'est pas
exactement quel et les pressions des
particules dans l'atmosphère
je pensais qu'on est obligé de faire des
prédictions probabiliste défaite met
d'ailleurs il me semble que c'est p
alors j'essaie but site et un sur dix
vit comme un philosophe qui avait
justement posé cette idée là que si on
connaissait l'état précis à chaque
instant de toutes les particules toutes
les forces de l'univers on pourrait
prévoir le futur avec certitude ouais
c'est pierre simon laplace et la place
d'accords mathématicien philosophe
préféré
voilà mais est-ce qu est-ce qu en disant
ça voilà ça me lance dans un autre truc
tu vois mais est ce que le libre arbitre
et pris en considération ou pas ou est
ce qu'on est dans cette idée qu'il n'y a
pas de libre arbitre puisque tous nos
actes sont donc déjà décidé
inconsciemment par des mécanismes qui se
déroule dans notre cerveau est ce qu'il
prenait en compte le libre arbitre ou ou
pas dans cette attitude
tout est attendue cette histoire de
armand donc donc la place a écrit ce
livre sur le traité en astronomie
et le conapp art d'un plomb bonaparte là
lui et selon la légende
[Musique]
happart a demandé à à la place il lui a
dit quelque chose comme newton part de
dieu dans son livre mais vous n'en
parlez pas pourquoi et la place aurait
répondu je n'ai pas eu besoin de cette
hypothèse là c'est super
quant à lui laissé du level de diogène
qui dit alexandre le grand au toit de
mon soleil
c'est ce genre de legrand dre partie
historique souvent plus dans la légende
d'ailleurs métier et or était un message
assez profond que dire que dit la place
parce qu'en fait newton il avait ce
problème que moi je dirais beaucoup mais
n'étonne il avait cette histoire dont
ils avaient découvert des lois ni loi de
la gravité et axa et du coup il se poser
ensuite la question de bon imaginons que
c'est des lois universelles grand
postulat que les lois qui s'appliquent
partout en quittant les questions qui se
posaient c'est que est-ce que du coup ça
ça implique tout ce qu'on observe en
particulier est ce que ça implique que
les planètes tournent bien comme il faut
autour autour du soleil et en fait c'est
une question difficile
ce qu'il a montré c'est que s'y ajuste
la terre et le soleil
alors la terre tourne bien autour du
soleil ça c'est des gars si ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui au lycée et cc c'est
déjà assez impressionnant et puis ça
fait des ellipses comme y faut que ça
s'il y avait juste jupiter et le soleil
alors jupiter tournera autour du soleil
jusque là tout va bien
mais la question qui se pose est ensuite
c'est supposons maintenant qui est
jupiter la terre et le soleil
est ce que la terre tourne toujours tout
le temps autour du soleil et newton a
essayé de démontrer sa a sans doute
et il a sans doute pas réussi et du coup
ce qui s'est dit c'est une lectrice et
que pour garantir le fait que la terre
tourne bien autour du soleil
sachant qu'il ya jupiter le soleil et la
terre il faut enfin ça veut dire des
trucs très compliqué et il faut un grand
horloger qui de temps en temps règles un
peu sa machine pour que ça continue à
fonctionner ok donc ça qu'il a invoqué
dieu pour expliquer que la terre tourne
autour du soleil même si à jupiter
d'accord c'est toi elles sont qui a
partagé récemment ce truc complètement
contre intuitif sur l'orbité de vénus
ouais c'est guinaudeau 6g pigray
incroyable ça fait que sur le fait que
mercoeur est la plus proche planète de
la terre mais ça oui 8
donc alors rappelons l'idée way le le
titre de la vidéo c'est donc dans cette
merde mercure vénus mercure vénus et
mercure en fait qui qui est tout le plus
souvent plus proche de la terre voilà
qui est plus souvent plus proche de la
terre est la démonstration est
implacable dit on ouais c'est parce que
la plupart du temps la plupart du temps
venus et de l'autre côté du soleil ou
alors en diagonale par rapport au soleil
du coup il est assez loin de la terre
alors que la distance entre la terre et
y mercoeur c'est quasiment directement à
distance au soleil je reprends de voir
la vidéo pour en savoir plus voilà wendy
possédant quelle planète est la plus
proche de la terre mars ou vénus
donc la réponse c'est mercure et il
explique donc avec une démonstration
implacable pourquoi et voilà je savais
que 70 kg les partager c'est
parfaitement le genre de deux
magnifiques pour lequel je vis pour
lequel je me lève chaque matin
s'apercevoir que
[Musique]
ben l'ordre compenser donc immuable
finalement est souvent très différents
de l'idée que l'on s'en fait quoi parce
qu'il ya vraiment cette idée pour moi
que la réalité le monde c'est d'abord
l'image qu'on en a en ce qui se passe
dans notre tête quoi et quand on
découvre ce genre d'information tout à
coup c'est comme s'ils avaient une mise
à jour de ce modèle parce qu'on vit tous
avec avec avec un modèle donc du coup
qui est la plupart du temps dans le
meilleur des cas
conditionnée par les meilleures
connaissances scientifiques qu'ils
soient les mêmes des modèles donc on a
un modèle basé sur des modèles et pour
moi c'est toujours il ya un petit côté
sorties de matrix quoi tu te confondre à
quelque chose qui bouscule ce modèle là
je pense c'est vachement important de
garder l'esprit suffisamment élastique
par rapport à tout cela ne te rencontrer
à tous tout remettre en question
[Musique]
sauf pour moi même mes limites c'est
quand même l'existence de l'existence de
la conscience conscience mélomanes al
sadd moi c'est ma limite personnellement
ouverture d'esprit
donc tout le reste je suis prêt à me
remettre en cause un bail c est tout à
fait d'accord avec ça j'irai même plus
loin c'est qu'il ya vraiment un plaisir
du puissance énorme à remettre en cause
son propre modèle il passé c'est
exactement le cas avec cette vidéo
sigi pilat et est donc pour en revenir à
la place c'est un peu le mind vague de
la place pasqua en fait newton il disait
que ces lois étaient universels mais en
fait il y croyait pas trop ce qu'il
disait qu'il fallait un grand or j'ai
dieu pour remettre de l'ordre
de temps en temps dans le système
solaire il appelait s'il a poussé un peu
plus loin les calculs
et enfin ses calculs suggérait a pas de
faits démontrés mais ça suggérait que en
fait non il n'ya pas besoin d'un grand
horloger les lois de newton suffisent à
expliquer pourquoi ce que la terre
continue à tourner autour du soleil même
si à jupiter et le mind fac de 2 de la
place de ceux d'hier du coup les lois du
town suffisent il n'y a plus besoin
d'hypothèses additionnel n'y a plus
besoin de se poser que dieu existe et du
coup il ya plus besoin non plus de
supposer que la conscience existe donc
on ne voit pas la librairie plus tôt
c'est lui qui tire vraiment savez cet
argument jusqu'au bout et illustre sa
avec cette histoire de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le démon de la place
quelqu'un qui connaît un des monstres
est capable de connaître toutes les
positions de toutes les particules et
qui applique réagissent les lois de
méthode il serait capable de prédire
tous le futur et tout le passé mais
qu'est ce que tu penses de ça d'ailleurs
tu penses que ce serait effectivement
suffisant reconnaissant seulement les
lois de newton ne vois pas ce que ça
semble applicable pour tout ce qui est
purement physique oui mais après tout et
tout et physique manière mais je ne sais
pas pour le mouvement des désastres le
mouvement d'un caillou que con qu'on
jette
je sais pas moi dans un jardin là on a
des choses qui peuvent sembler
facilement prévisible si on a les bonnes
données
mais pour toute la complexité par
exemple de dudu du vivant ça semble
délirant vous dire que même si on
connaît la position des particules on
peut prévoir par exemple ce qui pourra
advenir de du vivant d être capable
justement de de décision et de donner un
titre assez c'est vrai que c'est assez
fou qu'on réfléchisse à paris de la
place finalement qui pense que c'était
pas rester à l'époque de napoléon donc
c'est à la fin du xviiie tél débute ici
de rien à une époque où par exemple
darwin et je passe il est né à cette
époque il devait être déjà tu m'aimais
théorie de darwin et n'existait pas
encore comprenez très très mal le vivre
électricité commence à être un petit peu
on comprenait pas trop électricité ou et
où il y avait encore plus de mystère
aujourd'hui sur surtout plein de choses
mais la place a quand même fait ce pari
tu démontes la place disons que voilà
l'état présent de l'univers plus ces
lois physiques de l'univers suffisent
pas tous prédire d'accord ça me semble
moi un peu un peu gonflé un peu
expéditif comme la tarte à la place way
est très gonflé très expéditif mais j'en
prends plus si je m'abuse
moi ce que ce que tu en penses mais on
sait maintenant que ça évidemment la
presse voulait pas savoir mais on sait
que dans le domaine de la de la physique
quantique
il ya des choses pour lesquelles on peut
juste pas connaître de position ouais
général est tombé en même temps et c'est
alors la mécanique quantique à sa future
apple bordel en plus à evans est si je
suis l'histoire donc de la place à des
bus des 800 et quelques mois dire et
jusque et tout au long du xixème siècle
en fait il ya enfin tous les éléments
vont aller dans le sens de la place les
équations électromagnétisme l'ue
commencent à se rendre compte que voilà
dans le corps humain en fait c'est des
signaux électriques finalement qui
conduisent à qui enfin tous les messages
sont trop chimique et petit à petit on
identifie les particules le tableau de
mendeleïev voilà tous a dit ce même
siècle
on est vraiment dans cette lignée
ensuite mme stein avec l'acte est
général mais là ça reste encore dans
cette lignée l'étape présent détermine
de futures et puis et puis au xxème
siècle en 1926 9 30
patatras j'en ai deja de la mécanique
quantique qui quitte ea appareils qui y
semble remettre des choses pas mal de
choses
en doute et le truc c'est que en fait la
mécanique et la mécanique quantique est
très difficile à interpréter
il ya encore des débats des débats sans
fin sur ea bonne interprétation
américaine quantique et en fonction des
interprétations on peut soit être plutôt
du côté de la place soit être notamment
il ya une intervention ce qu'ils
appellent une interprétation de baume de
brogues avec des gens de pilotes quand
c'est un truc tout à fait déterminés à
la place on va dire mais il ya des trucs
bizarres calme et sarah c'était à la
place
sinon il ya l'interprétation la plus
classique et qui en termes de
probabilités cercle parfois il ya des
trucs probabiliste qui interviennent
dans la mécanique quantique s'appelle
parfois l'interprétation de copenhague
est un peu là l'interprétation la plus
standard conte ancien mécanique
quantique
quand je peux des lillois pourra parler
de mécanique quantique
il va présenter cette interprétation de
copenhague et du coup là il ya un truc
un peu bizarre parce qu'à des
probabilités du qu'on peut se dire
qu'être que le libre arbitre n'est de
ces probabilités mais ça sa part assez
bizarre parce que les les probabilités
en fait d'un viking quantiques sont sont
vraiment du hasard on peut faire passer
plein de tests et c'est vraiment c'est
pas que c'est pas que c'est pas ben
c'est pas que quelqu'un vous choisissez
que si s'il choisit pisser il choisit
exactement quand on choisira le hasard
du coup on fait peut pas vraiment
choisir tant que ça donc il oblige
respecter la loi des grands nombres
ouais du coup le côté hazard n'explique
pas du tout le libre arbitre
alors oui ce truc aussi je vous condamne
à discuter de cette impossibilité
lui-même de réellement donc
choisir des nombres aléatoires ouais ça
si ça peut paraître dingue je veux dire
justement quand on s'est pas penché sur
la question
a priori on ziba pourquoi je peux très
bien cité suite de chiffres aléatoires
et j'aurai un nombre qui relèvera du pur
hasard et on fait en fait non non en
fait non c'est on a assez prévisible et
plusieurs aspects pour lesquels il est
président mais vente uniquement on dit
plus souvent si on demande à quelqu'un
de dire à chier 3 ar beaucoup de gens
qu'on dira le chiffre 7
alors d'accord pour décor pour un
chiffre mais si par exemple s'il s'agit
d'un nombre à à sept chiffres
ben alors là je suis parfois faire un
peu plus
l'étude mais ce qu est ce qui a été fait
comme études si on demande aux gens de
de tirer des pile ou face au hasard dans
leur tête qui disputent eux respirent
lorsque les gens font ça en fait ils
disent beaucoup moins de longues suites
de piles de longues suites de face que
ne le ferait le hasard on peut faire
distinguer ce que les gens disent de ce
que le hasard dirait un problème mais je
t'en reparle aussi je crois
j'étais allé filmer dans les locaux de
cloud fleurs qui donc une société de
cryptage de données qui est basée à san
francisco et donc dans les dom dans les
halls d'entrée d'ailleurs de cette
société il ya un mur de laval m ce donc
cesser ces lampes de l'inpi là avec du
plasma multicolores donc qu'ils oublient
août à l'intérieur et qui crée du coût
des motifs aléatoire et dont pour
générer je ne le dis pas pour toi là du
coup jeudi paul gens qui nous écoutent
parce que tout succès mais pour générer
du coût des chiffres aléatoires et des
caméras braquées sur ce mur de la vans
et sacré du hasard pour créer des clés
de cryptage impossible quasiment
impossible à casser parce que du coup
même les ordinateurs eux mêmes ont du
mal à générer des nombres aléatoires
sans l'aide de
deux phénomènes qui sont aléatoires pour
le coup ouais c'est alors pourquoi en
fait voir ce qui marche les lampes à
l'aps on couvre pas vraiment du hasard
parce que ça suffit vraiment les doigts
enfin les lois de la physique me dire
voilà le priori a pas trop de
bizarreries identique appareils dedans
et souvent la place vous pourrez très
moi comment les formes sur lui toutes
les données on est d'accord
par contre c'est des phénomènes qu'on
appelle chaotique et ça se dire que des
petites perturbations peut-être juste
une voiture qui passe qui fait un peu de
bruit qui va faire des ondes sonores qui
vont perturber un petit peu strict
ça ça suffit a complètement changé ce
qui se passe dans la langue c'est
l'effet papillon
voilà c'est ça c'est exactement c'est
l'effet papillon il d'ailleurs là-bas et
encouragent à passer devant les longues
puisque du goût le fait de passer devant
les caméras et sa nacre et encore
davantage de matière à l'écran qui va
ajouter à la complexité
d'où cet âge là c'est ça c'est fou c'est
assez fou à la ça c'est un truc faut le
dire aux gens il faut dire que les
mécanismes de cryptage qui vous
permettent par exemple
voilà deux de consulter votre boîte mail
en étant assez certain qu'elle ne sera
pas piraté de faire des achats sur
internet en espérant qu'ils ne seraient
piratés
c'est en partie lié à un mur de place de
lanta placement dans une entreprise à
san francisco parce que je crois que
c'est vraiment une très très grosse
boîte comme fer qu'ils s'occupent de du
cryptage de plusieurs millions de sites
je trouve ça dingue de se dire que voilà
et des mécanismes donc ils sont
extrêmement secure comme ça à la base
peuvent reposer sur quelque chose
d'aussi trivial qu'un mur de la malène
ce qu'on peut acheter dans les boutiques
de souvenirs
voilà rigole pas avec le hasard à la
spada de place au hasard pour générer le
hasard
c'est vraiment critique parce que tu es
si on demande à des humains de
déchiffrer au hasard comme ça en fait il
y aura des régularités sera pas du but
du bon hazard
du coup ça c'est des failles ensuite que
les hackers peuvent les exploiter et
blue c'est vraiment important et
difficile de générer du hasard il ya un
site web aussi type qui permet de
s'appelle random.org il faut qu'ils ont
fait ils ont des capteurs dans
l'atmosphère où je peux chez ma poche et
je pense pas trop je n'aime pas trop les
détails mais en gros c'est par rapport à
certains trucs dans l'atmosphère du cou
qui généra des nombres aléatoires on
observant l'atmosphère d'accord et puis
le summum tu as des gens qui utilisent
la mécanique quantique pour générer du
hasard et ça serait du coup le meilleur
hasard ça coûte un peu plus cher à
produire du coup parce que divisés en
photo à chaque fois meilleur exemple est
fermée bio de récemment sur
l'informatique quantique ou actes
injustes par ben ouais ça fait un
épisode là dessus avec sur string theory
j'avais fait part et d'informatique
quantique c'est assez amusant parce que
d'un point de vue d'un informaticien
ce qui est bizarre mécanique quantique
pascal imite le hasard lire en encadré
l'informatique ou sait gérer bazar fait
partie souvent des modèles
par contre il ya des trucs bizarres
mécanique quantique qui on est heureux
c'est surtout à voir avec l'intrication
notamment lorsque intrigue plusieurs
particules le nombre d'états que l'on
créé est exponentielle dans le nombre de
de particules que l'on m'ait munich si
on a une particule on a deux états si on
a de particulier à 4 et à trois parties
qu on a huit états si on a quatre
particuliers on a 16 et a été multiplié
par deux à chaque fois au québec comme
comme dans tous vos calculs
exponentielle comme ça ça s'emballe très
très vite
et c'est à 100 balles pour le couvre un
très très haut puisque il suffit de 300
particules donc 300 particules c'est
vraiment entretien même pas de relancer
tout optique pour avoir plus d'état que
le nombre de particules dans tout
l'univers travail meirieu qui peut même
mais c'est comme c'est comme d'ailleurs
le nombre de combinaisons dans un jeu
d'échecs et les plus grands canaux des
particules en hiver ça s'est tellement
vertigineux aussi à se dire que
finalement on peut tenir dans nos mains
quelque chose qui potentiellement y est
supérieur au nombre de particules dans
l'univers quoi cc c'est tellement
vertigineux m
j'aime tellement ça mais sur l'homme sur
le truc de l'informatique quantique oui
par rapport à l'intrication donc il
semble que l'une des propriétés de
l'intrication quantique c'est que si on
prend deux particules intriquées quand
on met une un bout de l'univers et
l'autre à l'autre bout si on a une donc
qui qui change d'état par exemple
l'information va se propager
instantanément à l'autre particules on
est d'accord c'est bien ça l'idée oui ça
dépend aussi des interprétations
américaines quantique
comment les gens interprètent les choses
mais bowie et là on arrive aussi à
limiter donné de ma propre pension n'est
d'accord quant à elles toutes
potentiellement peut-être on dit des
bêtises placide david loix pr nous
écoute il pourra me corriger mais pas
jusque là des choses et on y dépose avec
le cas du territoire est d'accord bon
d'accord ça va là bas alors voilà donc
il ya cette idée que des particules
intriquées peuvent communiquer peuvent
communiquer instantanément même sèche à
deux extrémités opposées de l'univers ça
veut dire que l'information dans ce cas
là est plus rapide que la lumière
ac c'est là où l'a d'ailleurs pas
compliqué parce que l'art est même la
notion de instantanément n'a plus
vraiment de sens qu'on parle de plaies
très très éloignées la cause de
relativité restreinte
parce que la côte à retirer ce point que
les trucs sont très très loin on peut
penser que c'est dans le futur mais sur
le chemin que de référence il regretté
dans notre patrie française il était un
peu bizarre
et puis il ya aussi le fait de
transmettre l'information c'est des
trucs que je comprends pas très bien
exactement ce qu'ils lisent ensemble je
pense que personne ne peut prétendre
comprendre totalement ce qui se passe à
ce niveau là quoi d'accord au sein je
savais scharf mêmes qui disaient même
personne ne comprend vraiment la
physique quantique 22 puis le dantec et
on la comprend un peu mieux mais
personne ne peut prétendre avoir donc
saisi le la totalité de ce que ça de ce
que ça implique quoi ouais je pense je
pense aussi que c'est l'un des gros
problème c'est que si on regarde
vraiment au coeur dernier quand je pense
que les experts sont pas d'accord sur
l'interprétation de mécanique quantique
yvon particulier vous pu imaginer les
experts ans de procès sur lequel ils
seraient pas d'accord sur espèces
implique
ouais c'est là dessus que tu as fait ta
vidéo sur gerald steinberg août à perte
une vidéo avec une erreur einstein
non j'ai pas encore regardé ça parle pas
de ça on en a fait l'erreur de karine
parle de décès dont parlait un peu avant
la sueur stabilité du système solaire
d'accord parce que du coup la place
avait conclu que l'univers est stable
afin que le système solaire et stade
maison à l'époque que linux le système
solaire et l univers et einstein a
rejeté les lois de newton une autre de
relativité générale mais restait
persuadé que l'univers était stable oui
il était père s'avérer d'entre eux qui
étaient impliqués par la théorie qu'il
venait de rejeter le corps ah oui pas
mal moi quand j'ai dû la plus grande
erreur de stein j'ai cru que ça faisait
rend justement à sa position sur la
physique quantique jamais cru à sa fille
c'est un peu compliqué la relation dan
klein avec avec un cantique mais en gros
il ya cru il pensait jusque-là mécanique
quantique était incomplète que son
interprétation fondamental dans
l'adaptation de copenhague était erroné
c'est le fameux dieu ne joue pas aux dés
ouais c'est exactement ce qu'il pensait
pas qu'il y avait ces probabilités mais
en un sens si on peut c'est difficile de
dire qu'il a tort puisque je pense que
beaucoup de physiciens d'aujourd'hui qui
serait d'accord avec lui que
l'enterrement si on prend les deux
autres interprétations duquel il ya une
autre intervention je pense que j'en
avais pas parlé c'est la théorie du
multivers quantique c'est de dire que
fait ce qu'on croit être
donc quand on observe particules et bien
événements aléatoires qui qui se produit
si on prend une autre habitation de
copenhague
en fait la théorie des multivers dit non
non en fait c'est pas un truc aléatoire
qui se produit ce qui s'est passé c'est
que on est rentré en intrication avec
l'objet qu'on a observés et que ja il ya
deux mondes qui se sont créées il ya un
monde qui est créé où on est intrigué
avec la particule qui est dans son état
dans un état a et on est dans un autre
univers quantique on est intrigué avec
la l'autre version de cette particule
d'accord il coûte tout ça me fait penser
au docteur manhattan dans watchmen tu
écris tu sais pas si tu connais le
comics non écoute docteur manhattan
pour moi c'est un des personnages de
fiction les plus fascinants qui soit
c'est une personnage de fiction préférée
je pense et j'en parle parce que donc là
en ce moment il ya la série watchmen qui
diffusait sur ses récents moi je la
regarde siro cs hier soir j'ai vu un
épisode qui va retourner le cerveau et
donc la série est adapté d'un comics
culte donc qui date du début des années
80 qui a été scénarisé par alan moore et
qui est considéré comme un des des
comics les plus les plus brillants dans
son écriture les plus adultes en tout
cas qu'ils abordent des thèmes
qu'on voit rarement à l'époque dans les
comics et donc à ce personnage du dr
manhattan qui est capable qui est un
dieu vivant en fait c'est un univers de
super héros dans lequel n'ya pas de
super héros en fait c'est juste des gens
normaux qui mettent des masques et qui
vont combattre le crime un peu comme
batman et il ya un personnage qui a des
super pouvoirs qui s'appelle le docteur
manhattan et qui est à la base un
physicien qui se retrouve enfermé dans
une sorte d' accélérateur de particules
quelque chose dans ce goût là et il est
désintégré et puis se réintègrent est là
donc il se transforme en une espèce
d'être omniscient omnipotent qui peut
manipuler la matière à volonté il peut
contrôler tout le tout le réel quoi
remodeler les particules transformer une
arme en bouquets de fleurs voilà donc ce
personnage en devenant une espèce de
divinités omnipotente finit par
s'éloigner progressivement des
préoccupations humaines par exemple pour
le docteur manhattan ya pas de
différence entre une personne vivante et
une personne morte
pour lui c'est un assemblage de
particules très similaires quoi et voilà
espèce de détachement comme ça qui est
hélas donc dans la série qui se passe du
coup un peu plus de trente ans après le
comics évidemment les personnages
docteur manhattan a été abordée
progressivement parce que c'est un peu
l'élément clé du du truc et et il se
trouve que justement lui ce personnage
tu parlais tout à l'heure de lui tendre
la relativité
il vit dans toutes les dimensions du
temps à la fois vis à la fois dans son
passé il vit dans le futur il est dans
une espèce de déterminisme total ça que
voilà il est simultanément dans le futur
a dans le passé donc il a jamais de
surprise
il sait exactement ce qu'il va arriver
et c'est vraiment un personnage
passionnant je te conseille chaudement
et à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
d'ailleurs qu'ils n'ont pas lu les
comics d'analysé watchmen ne serait ce
que pour le docteur manhattan et
d'ailleurs s'il est aussi un film de
zack snyder il sorti à quelques années
qui est très fidèle au comics et
qui vous permettra déjà d'avoir une
bonne idée de personnages mais ses
entrées c'est parfait pour les pour les
geeks qui s'intéressent à la science à
quai à regarder des coûts la ccir et
mende est ce que tu te sens tu as un nom
dessus
comment est ce que tu es les sujets
d'intérêt quand tu es ce que tu choisi
de s'intéresser à quelque chose et
comment est-ce que ça a évolué au cours
des ces raisons et bien souvent gdg des
emballements comme ça ponctuel pour des
sujets je vais creuser le truc des
semaines je vais me passionner pour
quelque chose pour un domaine je veux
dire tout ce que je peux sur le domaine
et puis je passe à autre chose et c'est
fin c'est ça qui est qui et qui est
formidable
quand quand on s'intéresse au caractère
surprenant et extraordinaire de réelles
finalement c'est que tout et tout est
matière à étonnement quel que soit le
domaine
on pourrait selon pourrait se plonger
dans n'importe quel domaine et même se
focaliser sur une sous catégorie d' une
sous-catégorie d'un domaine et ne pas
avoir assez d'une vie pour pour le
[Musique]
l'explorer en entier quoi région je
pense à l'histoire par exemple
l'histoire avec un grand h c'est une
source de fascination infinie et
maintenant on peut se focaliser sur une
période de l'histoire
jean sur un siècle précis et sur un
siècle précis au sein d'une culture
précise d'un pays précis et ne pas avoir
assez d'une vie pour en faire le tour
et ça pour moi c'est un bonheur total
quoi se dire que on n'arrivera jamais à
bout de toutes les choses passionnantes
qui peuvent exister et en plus
généralement quand on commence à
s'intéresser à différents sujets ça nous
aurons sur d'autres sujets c'est cette
idée que plus plus on en apprend plus on
prend conscience de notre ignorance
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que c'est sans
fin qu'ont fait couvert des portes qui
s'ouvrent sur des portes
et donc voilà moi c'est mes coups de
coeur que je peux pas expliquer c'est à
dire que tout à coup voilà je vais
vraiment me focaliser sur sur un sujet
dont je réfléchisse il ya un truc en
particulier ans allemand qui m'a qui m'a
intéressé laisse moi réfléchir un petit
peu j'adresse à me récemment par exemple
je me suis intéressé aux connexions
improbable qu'il pouvait y avoir entre
des personnages célèbres personnages
illustres ça dingue ça déjà c'est une
spirale quoi contourner avec moi c'est
incroyable
par exemple ne fait que samuel beckett
l'auteur était un proche de andré le
géant qui était un catcheur de la wwf
hulk hogan et tout ça le heurter coeur
donc voilà andré léger ans est un
catcheur français qui était une star de
la wwf donc la célèbre ligue 2 4
américaine et c'est tellement improbable
de se dire qu'il ya une connexion entre
samuel beckett dramaturge célébrissime
et en allégeant pourquoi parceque il se
trouve que andré le géant dont qu'ils
étaient français
et quand il était enfant donc c'est
samuel beckett qui a vécu en france qui
le conduisait à l'école dans sa voiture
parce que le bus de l'école était trop
petit pour andré le géant qui comme son
nom l'indiqué dettinger en voilà et ça
bon une fois que tu as commencé à mettre
le nez là dedans par exemple les to be
free donc le boys band
les amicalistes oublie fruits ont pris
les cours de danse avec lucette
destouches qui était la femme de louis
ferdinand céline
l'auteur est d'ailleurs lucette
destouches
elle est morte et à quoi peut être
quinze jours à l'âge de 107 ans là on a
une folle norman phoque voilà je veux
toi je me suis plongée maintenant et
aussi à ça c'est thomas vdb qui me l'a
appris
le fait que dick rivers
le chanteur dick rivers qui a eu lieu si
pinson dame est décédée
a failli être le beau père de george
lucas ce de stars las comment c'est
possible
et bien parce que donc georges ducasse
est sorti avec la fille de dick rivers
et donc ils auraient dû l'épousé et ça
ne s'est pas fait mais si la leaf et
dick rivers aura été de fait le beau
père de 80 ans c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres mais ça peut être n'importe
quoi comme ça et quand je commence à m'y
intéresser je me plonge dedans et
généralement ça me permet de mettre de
côté doit désinformation des faits des
connaissances pour mon plaisir personnel
bien sûr pour mon émerveillement
personnel mais aussi pour nourrir
ensuite ce que je pourrais faire sur le
papier en vidéo ben là notamment pour
accès 5
je suis en train de collecter le plus
possible de l'histoire de ce genre parce
que dans les bd ac ce lot il ya des
pages cabinet de curiosités justement
c'est que des histoires comme ça que des
faits écrit il n'y a pas de dessein que
je donc que je collecte pour les points
les bébés spécifiquement et voilà donc
c'est une chance inouïe en fait de
pouvoir concilier cette passion pour
pompes pour les choses surprenantes de
notre planète avec mon activité
professionnelle du coup que les que les
deux soient interdépendants c'est une
chance inouïe que je mesure chaque jour
des rêves je peux faire une soumission
de des sujets d'intérêt oui vu qu est ce
qu a été entendu par les deux humoristes
gallois alors mais toi même tu en as
parlé d'ailleurs way à plusieurs
reprises et jeudi à paris un régal
alors attends attends attends parce
qu'il me semble que la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus on avait parlé ici je me
souviens bien à
oui oui evariste galois donc c'est ce
mathématicien brillant inquiets bonne
mort bêtement à cause d'un duel qu'il a
perdu non et avant de faire ce duel il
avait posé si je ne m'abuse un tube
corrigé il avait posé un théorème
encore aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas
totalement à
à comprendre c'est sa part beaux arts
par l'interception une théorie mais oui
au fait la théorie de galles et ma
figure toi par rapport à ça parce que
oui on peut toujours trouver des
connexions comme ça entre divers sujets
champions dans certains que le délai d
le dernier duel en france s'est passé au
20e siècle les habituels deux derniers
duels d'honneur donna l'impression que
c'est un truc qui est qui reléguait j'en
sais rien moi au 17e et en fait pendant
le dernier s'est passé en france et il
s'est passé dans les années 60
figure toi et c'était entre le maire de
l'époque n'était pas encore maire de
marseille c'était entre gaston defferre
qui est devenu par la suite maire de
marseille et un autre homme politique
dont j'ai oublié le nom donc vous pouvez
taper dans google dernier duel gaston
defferre par exemple vous aurez le nom
de son opposant et c'est parti d'une
brouille
alors que donc élise et et je pense à
l'assemblée nationale ouais il y en a un
qui s'est moqué de l'autre est celui qui
justement s'était fait moquer l'avait
provoque un duel d'ambitieux pour laver
mon honneur
je vous provoque en duel et ils l'ont
fait m battue sauf que comme c'était au
xxème siècle il ya des fautes ont traité
vidéo c'est conçu ce dieu belle et il
s'est arrêté au premier sens et tu crois
que c'est gaston defferre qui a gagné et
voilà dès que dès que son a coulé aux us
est arrêté et sa marque le dernier duel
officielle de l'histoire de france
figure toi et le général de gaulle
trouvé ça totalement
un ridicule et absurde et empêcher le
duel bien quand même
donc voilà aimer la vie aux gallois il
ya beaucoup de choses
il ya pas mal de chance et il a joué de
malchance toute sa vie et à côté de ça
il avait cette théorie révolutionnaire
en fait ils voyent écrivait comme un
comme un cochon quoi du coup j'aimerais
qu'il se mériter un truc à l'académie
les gens arrivaient pas lire ce que
c'était une rature et de partout il ya
il a soumis des des mémoires aussi qui
ont été perdus par fourier je crois
l'autre par couche y avoir on a joué de
malchance
son père était maire de bourg la reine
et s'est fait tué la veille et concours
à l'école polytechnique et du couloir
atc concours lendemain moi j'adore ça
les voilà en plus dans ce moment
j'aimerais relancer le concept des
actions portrait avec des personnages
comme ça on peut ou des listes un peu
méconnu et des destins incroyables
c'est d'ailleurs exactement le principe
de la vie et finalement c'est des gens
qu à l est du coup oui ça m'intéresse
totalement d'autant que j'ai vraiment
l'impression que dans le domaine de la
science il ya des portraits inouïe quoi
rit souvent le génie coincide quand même
assez souvent avec avec une certaine
folie et il ya des trucs bas par exemple
newton moi j'avais apprises j'avais
appris ça dans le fabuleux bild le bill
fameux livre de bill bryson que je jure
que je recommande toujours qui est une
histoire de tous ou presque mais pas
[Musique]
de quelques scientifiques illustre
justement en disant que ben voilà des
gens comme newton
quand on en parle c'est d'habitude pour
parler justement de leur découverte donc
en concurrence avec noten voilà
d'invitation à la peau avec c
mais ce qu'on sait moins c'est que
newton était aussi versé en alchimie par
exemple mais qu il n est pas à une
bizarrerie près notamment quand il
s'enfonce et donc une aiguille à
tricoter du film sous le globe oculaire
pour provoquer donc des phénomènes
visuels qui l'étudié l'optique s'établit
qu'à attendre quand c'est possible de
dire quand un gars qui a posé la théorie
qui nous a permis d'appréhender le réel
pendant des siècles il se foutait des
aiguilles à tricoter dans l'oeil one
hand et voilà ça ça me régale
personnellement donc là je connais pas
mal de films lui assure des
mathématiciens brahmanes aux jaloux ou
turing des histoires assez folle qu'on
s'entête concept est reconnue mais
gallois c'est gallas et ses iphone
je veux me pencher là il y avait la
pression pile à la veille de son duel en
fait il est pris de panique et c'est là
qu'il décide de d'enfants et expliquer
ses idées c'est dingue ça tellement fou
tellement fou c'est comme quand même
parlé aussi comme maïorana ouais ok ce
mathématicien génial aussi qui a disparu
traitement c'est etienne klein qui en a
pas mal parlé en conférence a fait un
livre dessus d'ailleurs pareil qu'un
type comme ça
visionnaire du aussi il me semble il à
hilla il a écrit des choses qui sont
seulement comprise aujourd'hui et il a
disparu
c'est tellement c'est tellement
romanesque en fait voilà source de
fascination sent qu'il ya aussi les
destins surprenant d des gens il ya eu
l'air aussi une vidéo sur youtube qui
s'appelle étudier ailleurs bernard dolez
leur or là pour le coup c'est plus que
le mec est juste le vainqueur a perdu un
oeil et sa sa productivité a augmenté
après la perte du deuxième oeil et sa
productivité encore patienter
non ça c'est pas du tout alors avec je
cherchais ça c'est fou le banc parce que
le télescope qui a un des télescopes qui
a un observateur de l'acien ouchy
s'appelle le le télescope de leurs
d'ailleurs ces télescopes suisse et
voilà ça me fait penser du coup je sais
absolument pas qu'il avait perdu ses
yeux bandés beaucoup en allemagne c'est
le plus impressionnant c'est le plus ne
peux plus je pense que c'est le mec le
plus impressionnant des histoires des
matins lequel tu dit john von neumann à
d'accord ok peut-être moins connus que
les autres mais rassure sa page
wikipédia est une section spéciale sur
vie bien sûr à quel point était brillant
que d'accord et des votes des histoires
tant que j'aurai un autre mac matière à
jour qui qui environnement chez lui puis
quand ça avoirs d'un homme en parler à
son
pis ils voient que von neumann fait un
effort en jouant son fils et du coup il
fait un effort pour parler plus
lentement qu'espéré
il a il se rend compte que goldman fait
la même chose à chaque fois qu'il parle
à lui waouh
hu [ __ ] ça aussi c'était vachement
intéressant quoi mais des gens comme ça
qui semble avoir une espèce de
collection de collection privilégié avec
avec le réel
d'ailleurs avec avec des ddd des
connaissances qui peuvent sembler très
très très ésotérique comme ça ils sont
quand en phase avec la trame même de la
réalité mais comment ils peuvent avoir
cette espèce de connexion comment tout à
coup une personne débarque et comprend
des choses que des millions avant elle
n'avait pas comprises ça c'est quelque
chose dont il use de vraiment fascinant
à ça tout à coup une personne va saisir
va avoir une espèce de fulgurances alors
qu'avant elle pendant des milliers
d'années bay les milliers de personnes
qui sont passés par le même chemin et
qu'elle est pas un
je trouve ça passionnant et s'est
personnellement ce qui me donne un
espoir illimitée en l'humanité parce que
l'histoire prouve que oui parfois il ya
des gens qui qui surgissent comme ça 3 4
fois par siècle et qui révolutionne tous
quand tout ce qu'on croyait être vrai et
c c'est inouï
ouais moi l'impression assez c'est plus
que et donc les mecs vraiment brillant
comme ça pas au punch line ils sont
passés là où d'autres ont passé avant
mais ils y sont elles ont pris une
trajectoire un peu différentes raisons
tu vois un petit truc un peu un peu
différent dans leur parcours et des
rencontres un peu différente et cesse
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont eu une autre
façon de regarder les choses
oui il parle pas 0 marche sur dix
marches sur les épaules des géants qui
est qui et qui est et ouest puis
donc tout le monde a suivi une certaine
trajectoire mais ils ont aussi une
structure un peu différentes et ils ont
eu une frappe et ça de la chance et
peut-être un peu peu fort quoi mais là
ils ont eu un truc un peu différent il
faut qu'ils ont vu les choses sous un
autre angle de par exemple darwin on
raconte beaucoup
il raconte lui-même que il ya ce voyage
autour du monde avec le beagle en bateau
beaucoup d'espèces différentes
guy ne pas suivi le même chemin que tout
le monde quoi
einstein ça aussi c'est cet aspect ouais
il fait pas le parcours classique parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver un poste
mais voilà du coup ils obligeaient de
tenter des trucs différemment du coup
ils voient l'ont un peu différemment
bahamas ça c'est le jeu sans cela
ternisse bilingue de bahia clairement ça
se joue énormément et après il ya des
trucs des mecs comme common man qui est
juste calcul plus vite
oui voilà des fois c'est cesser purement
et maintenant physique voilà il ya des
gens qui ont un meilleur ordinateur dans
la tête que les autres ouais ouais c'est
assez fascinant quoi je pas si tu as vu
là une semaine il se gausse quoi de 8 9
ans un petit belge qui va être le plus
jeune jeunes diplômés de l'histoire donc
à 8 ans j'ai eu son bac et là il va être
diplômé de je ne sais plus quoi mais ça
va être que ça va être le plus jeune
quoi l'histoire l'a jamais vu ça waouh
mais qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'elle est
différent que mécaniquement qu'est ce
qui se passe dans sa tête
est-ce que c'est insultant est-ce qu'on
est tous vous et un jour fonctionner
beaucoup plus rapidement être ça
questionne quoi ouais
aujourd'hui le la personne reconnue
comme étant la plus haute et
mathématicien le plus brillant monde
d'hier c'est karine strauss kahn on
attend c'est non non non je confonds
avec le russe na qui a résolu à
l'épreuve les nerfs qui a refusé son
prix
dr hans klaus est quelqu un bon jour
life is an et où toutes les distinctions
mathématique d'une histoire récente a ou
par mois
tu as des physiciens qui galérait avec
un truc
et puis on trouvait une équation il
n'arrive pas à savoir si c'était vrai
ils ont prié dans la littérature sont
jamais vu ça du coup ils ont envoyé un
e-mail à terrance town et deux heures
plus tard une carte à opérer pour a
répondu ali belle avec trois
démonstrations différentes
c'est tellement fou mais c'est comme ce
gars alors là par contre j'ai plus le
nom en tête mais qui a inspiré ensuite
l'histoire de good will hunting je crois
donc l'histoire c'est que le type
arrivent en retard en classe et ils
voient des équations au tableau et il
est notes de ce qu'il pensait que
c'étaient les devoirs pour le cours
d'arrêt et il résout les équations et
est en fait ils aperçus après coup que
c'était des équations que personne
n'avait jamais résolu et le prof les a
déposés sur le tableau en exemple de
d'équations irrésolu quoi et c'est en
corrigeant ce sont son devoir que le
prof s'en est aperçu qu il est vrai que
vous avez résolu deux équations qui
tient dans les chaînes thématiques tient
depuis toujours et j'ai oublié le nom du
gars ça me frustre des rentrées sept ans
mais voilà ce genre de truc est aussi là
un peu l'idée comme comme il savait pas
que c'était impossible
il a il a fait quoi à ségécé georges
danzig dont 6000 une autre histoire et
d'antillais evanno vannes ou du coup
quand il était devenu aussi l'expert
mondial dans tout qui s'appelle la
programmation linéaire
un jour il arrive à princeton princeton
c'est là où il y arrive en oman il fait
une 30 à sion au tableau et au bout de
30 minutes 29 ans à venir non c'est pas
possible tu vas possible à ces tracés
vous et donc il rend l'atantique de sa
soirée après développe toute une
nouvelle théorie en temps réel comme ça
sa force force
lité le respect l'admiration et sa venue
dans l'espoir surtout en l'humanité quoi
forcément d'ailleurs de mettre en avant
davantage dans le personnage que je sais
pas moi
trump ses tweets il ya aussi des humains
qui donne espoir qu'on ne le risque
souvent c'est enfin beaucoup de gens
voient le risque que en parlant trop de
ses personnages vous donne un peu plus
impression encore que des mathématiques
au caire un génie particulier
ouais alors que moi je pense vraiment je
pense que ces gens là qui sont très très
forts ils ont en fait en effet une
petite supériorité par par quelqu un qu
à moins qu'il y avait un truc je pense
que génétiquement ils étaient le cap dur
vous dire moi je ne sais pas la
principale raison c'est ce qui est ce
qu'à fait la grosse différence c'est que
c'est surtout des gens passionnés que
c'est des gens aient enfin bon moi
pareil je pense que mon secret on va te
mettre à la raison pour laquelle j'ai le
niveau que j'ai en mathématiques
c'est vraiment juste parce que j'adore
ça oui que du coup je passe vraiment
énormément de temps à penser aux
mathématiques beaucoup plus que puisque
la plupart des gens c'est un peu une
trivialité mais beaucoup plus même que
des gens qui sont dans des choeurs ce
soit mathématique
je comprends parce que personnellement
il ya des tas de sujets qui ont commencé
à me passionner
quand j'ai quand j'ai quitté l'école
justement à l'école il y a il ya ce côté
rébarbatif qui vient de l'obligation
d'éducation et avec évidemment c'est pas
forcément les côtés les plus
passionnants où les plus fascinants qui
sont mis en avant à l'école les profs
doit se tenir un programme est donc bon
dans une vidéo de vulgarisation
forcément on va faire des vikings en
attendant les choses qui nous intéresse
le plus est j'ai un point complet
évidemment c'est plus compliqué de faire
ça et donc voilà ce conte est
obligatoire de l'école fait que beaucoup
de gens passent à côté des merveilles de
certains certains domaines qu'il
s'agisse de qu'il s'agisse de
l'histoire comme des mathématiques ou la
littérature et moi personnellement
beaucoup de domaines comme ça pour
lesquelles je me suis passionné en
quittant l'école parce que je me suis
aperçu qu'en fait mais rien de plus
intéressant que les matières nous
enseigner à l'école s'en fout sauf que
souvent vous enseignez pas de la manière
la plus intéressante et en ce qui
concerne les maths malheureusement moi
je suis passé à côté l'époque parce que
je ne voyais donc qu'une matière qui
était hermétique et rébarbative
évidemment comme pour tout le reste
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser aux
maths par plaisir j'ai réalisé à quel
point c'était fascinant et je pense moi
que si c'est perçu comme un jeu 1 7 6 1
le jeu le plus passionnant qui soit
ouais bah car en vrai et je pense qu'en
maths aujourd'hui il n'y a pas besoin de
plus d'enseignements je pense qu'il ya
même pas face on n'a plus de
vulgarisation il ya besoin de beaucoup
plus d'émerveillement que par les matins
c'est vraiment être et qui manquent
et puis à l'idée que tu joues encore une
fois avec le code source de l'univers
d'une certaine manière la fin je suis
vraiment dans le code quoi et forcément
tu vois le monde d'autres maliens
arrêtés et tapez votre truc aussi ce que
je vais trouver un peu frustrant avec
les maths c'est que pour la plupart des
gens les maths s'arrête à l'école c'est
quelque chose de très scolaire associé à
l'école peter un peu cette idée que
celle ci dit et ça c'est très présent
chez pas mal de mathématiciens
professional ses idées sur laquelle si
t'as pas fait c'était pas mathématicien
à 20,3 en bas c'est fini pour toi tu
peux tu peux arrêter michael est un peu
il ya un peu cette idée quoi et alors
que c'est qu'il ya plein de contre
exemples de gens qui se sont intéressés
les matins à 30 ans il ya 40 ans qui
sont devenus très très très fort je suis
aussi ces profils que dans l'histoire
des maths crois que c'est d'ailleurs ce
tracé ne fera que c'est un d'entre eux
il ya un mec qui s'appelle le jeune
fille où il est pressenti pour almeida
et filles sont vraiment aujourd'hui
c'est un top d'interaction du monde et a
pendant longtemps ils pensaient qu'ils
étaient nuls en maths
il n'a pas fait d'études n'a pas du tout
changé il a fait des études en
journalisme tout genre ouais puis un
jour il devait interviewer un
mathématicien du coup du coup il allait
assister à son cours
il n'a rien compris mais il est allé
poser des questions et puis petit à
petit s'est intéressé aux maths et donc
fait le choix je pourrais être retrouvé
[Musique]
non mais ça c'est vraiment une histoire
ou trop vu que pour devenir bon en maths
c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir fait maths
sup maths spé
mais il ya d'autres chemins qui permet
d'être très nettes mais surtout en plus
aujourd'hui il semble avec la quantité
de la quantité de vidéos la quantité
d'articles qui sont facilement
accessibles sur internet
je pense qu'on peut se faire une auto
formation très rapide et plus efficace
si on s'intéresse suffisamment sujet
quoi si on est porté par justement goût
des mathématiques par une par une
passion des mathématiques
je pense que ouais c'est très facile
quel que soit le domaine mais c'est plus
facile que j'ai aujourd'hui de ceux de
se créer un bagage solide en autodidacte
avec tout le contenu gratuit à
disposition
je pense que ce qu'il a le plus manqué
va si on essaie d'être d'y aller en
autodidacte seul c'est le fait d'avoir
d'autres gens autour de nous scor en
fait d'une des crozes utilité de l'école
c'est que notamment en université on va
dire en mathématiques c'est qu'on est
aussi entouré de gens qui sont a priori
intéressée par les mathématiques et du
coup c'est plus facile et ce métier il
ya une émulation
c'est ça une émulation et un côté social
très important mais est ce que
finalement cette émulation tu peux pas
la retrouver
par le biais de
des réseaux par le biais de forums tu
peux aussi échanger avec des passionnés
de mathématiques très franches conteries
multi-packs a dit si ça remplace un mais
il semble qu'il faut aussi trouver une
certaine émulation sociale je pense je
pense carrément et puis enfin la
communauté des vulgarisateurs
scientifiques sur youtube
bah quoi bon maintenant je vous ai tous
rencontrés et quasiment mais pendant
longtemps c'était un truc on s'en va
s'envoyer des messages quoi parce qu'on
ne l'a jamais rouvrir me dire et ça
suffisait à être ultra stimulant mais
non c'est sûr que voilà du coup quand on
peut se rencontrer par le biais
d'événements quelques le festival fois
mis là pour faire des conférences aussi
passionnante que celle sur la nature de
la réalité
je regrette bien d'ailleurs qu'elle ait
pas été enregistrée celle là forcément
c'est autre chose que quand on se
contente de discuter on y suivait mais
c'est ça sa boîte une bonne combinaison
d'avoir faudra organiser ça et pour des
gens qui voudra pour les maths ça serait
un peu plouc et parce que de s'organiser
parce qu ils me demandent aux ja spécial
femmes ce qui nous fait bien honoré hier
donc voir l on appelle à présent de
secret de quoi que ce soit il faudra
qu'ils s'intéressent traumat et être un
peu plus compliqué mais ça pourrait être
cool d'avoir des idées aussi des rares
fois des trucs sur les réseaux sociaux
mais aussi des rencontres entre
passionnés que la même manière que nota
bene a créé l'un des historiques avec
eux des vulgarisateurs l'histoire en
battant intéressant de le faire avec
avec les maths et la physique charles
chéreau mais il va falloir que je te
laisse pantois si je dois partir
ce que pour toi ce qu'est ce que tu as
suffisamment de largement et à les
stocker votre cas merci beaucoup merci à
toi très chouette est très sympa rey
était liée et pour les éditeurs de jeux
vous dis à bientôt
probablement